highways committee the order as chair of
the committee I find that due to the
state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of covid-19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on bills referred to this committee
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
contemporar during this meeting through
the zoom electronic meeting platform and
the public there has access listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available from the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court
website the meeting notice for this
meeting complies with house rules and
RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
600 or email
HCS l. state. n. Us in the event the
public is unable to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting assisting
us Brad Greenland committee
researcher please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call vote let us start
the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
present please also indicate where they
are and if there is anybody in the room
with you during this meeting which is
law Mr clerk thank you Mr chair
representative Graham pres
representative Moni present
representative mids the clerk is here
representative Paul samaro I am here and
I am in a condominium down in South
Carolina with my
fidi representative
Newton repres yes I'm here I'm at home
and my wife is in the house somewhere
but she's not in this room with
me thank you representative BL
boards representative kazinski
here representative
kolansky I'm here home and my girlfriend
somewhere
around representative Thompson
Castile representative cluder uh present
in the committee room representative
Edgar present uh nobody's home right now
with me but uh my wife come might come
back representative
Alone representative Jack I'm here
inun representative Abbott here in the
committee room representative
fauler I'm here in Swansea um my wife is
in the other
room representative
Newman yes I'm here I'm in the room
house representative
grassie representative grass's here home
and
alone for record representative grassy
can I have your first name
please
chck representative
represent representative
query here and in Manchester
alone representative
bunker present in exitor my wife is
house thank you the attendance is
complete chairman uh thank you Mr clerk
um Mr Vice chairman we're ready to start
okay thank you for that
um we are going to open up house bill
122a and I will ask the prime sponsor to
introduce the bill I believe that would
be
representative thank you Mr chairman my
name is John gr I represent the town of
Bedford which is Hillsboro district 7 I
bring before you a bill to participate
in a public private partnership with two
railroad Railways in the state of New
Hampshire um this is not a new project
or situation for us in the past we have
heard similar bills to um partnership
and a 5050 bases with the railroads in
order to maintain their Capital which is
ties and rails um on these things the
reason that I support this is because
one it keeps uh rail TR traff moving
through the state some of which goes out
to Midwest and further south the other
reason is it keeps a lot of trucks heavy
trucks off the roads here in New
Hampshire it is better that we use great
Railways rather than having some of
these larger trucks up and down our
highways on a daily basis um I would ask
that we probably consider doing what we
have done the last two terms when we
exec this bill which is to retain the
bill and then see if we can work it into
the capital budget which we will get
next month it will probably not be at
the dollar amount that is in the bill
last term that we asked for two million
it was well less than a million each
that they got um so it depends on our
fiscal
ability whether we included and then
what amount in the capital budget if we
were to retain with that Mr chairman I
am willing to take questions but it's
pretty
straightforward um thank you
representative Graham are there any
questions for representative Graham at
this
time see none thank
you did you I'm sorry repres did you see
any other I didn't see
would like to call on representative
online yes I think I'm online now thank
you representative would you care to
speak yes I would I'm uh represent Coos
5 so this uh infrastructure project on
the St Lawrence in
Atlantic um will uh affect all of Coos
County and be an enormous plus to
maintaining infrastructure that's been
here for over 150 years but what we have
done in the last several years is
partner with as a state with St Lawrence
in Atlantic dollar for dooll
on a project to upgrade and modernize
the track so that heavier rail cars that
could carry more weight can now run uh
from Montreal to Maine and through the
northern part of New Hampshire
happily just at the moment Coos appears
to be having some good fortune on uh
major projects gorm pap
has become White Mountain paper and is
going to expand bring in another paper
machine and that is a customer that
could be here milin Lumber has just
announced a $12 million expansion that's
um someone who might ship on this rail
line so not only will we have uh rail
cars
and locomotives going through Coos
County but we have the potential to be
shipping from this place not only
shipping out but
importing Goods to be manufactured or
processed in these plants that are
expanding so I am Keen to see whether we
could get enough Capital to finish the
project
uh which has been going for close to 10
years now and uh so this is a
fundamental infrastructure project that
will bring economic uh good to Coos
which I might say needs it badly uh
we've been hard hit by the pandemic as
so much of New Hampshire has uh but we
didn't start out at the at the top of
the Heap and and so this project is very
important for uh Coos County I'd be
happy to I submitted some written
testimony uh I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank thank you representative
I'm glad to hear things are looking
better in your area are there any
Tucker seeing none thank you thank you
the chair Now call
please PA when you're
ready yes jamman my name just I'm just
unmuted
yes my video I guess
Mr chairman my name is Paul wwit I'm
here today uh representing the St
Lawrence Atlantic railroad I'm employed
by Gallagher cahan and got Trail in
coner New
Hampshire um again we this rail line
goes from gor gorm to Berlin to up to
North straford the um this project
really started back in
2010 when the capital budget Committee
in the in the house allocated $850,000
to be spent in rehabil heading the rail
uh since then in
201 uh 16 fiscally year
201617 the capital budget uh committee
allocated a 1.5 million but mandated
that it had to be matched dollar for
dollar and that bill passed and we
matched it dollar for
dollar so that um for the last two years
the the next two years uh it was
appropriated $1 million by the capital
budget of the House and Senate and
$900,000 in in in last fiscal year last
capital budget so it's been
appropriately approximately $6.8 million
has been authorized to rehabilitate this
line and we're getting it to the finish
of 3.4 from the private sector and 3.4
from the state but it's important to
note that this project is under the
supervision of the Department of
Transportation rail division U they
Agreements are assigned
and go to governor and councel for
approval what's important in those
agreements among other things is that
the state maintains a lean on the
property for 10 years and also in the
agreement we are required to maintain
the rail to the status that we were
upgraded to in this case we're get
upgrading it to class two Rail and that
um means 25 miles hour for freight
trains and the um so we have to maintain
it that again as representative trer
said we've had some new companies coming
in uh I believe it's because of seeing
the investment in the area by the state
and and the railroad and we've been
working closely with um uh the u
bino u to and to attract business to the
uh to this to this
area and we've also um Canadian Council
and we've been very active in trying to
recruit companies to located in this
area so with the allocation if this
money was to go through it would
complete the project uh to the finish
and with that uh I have Charles Hunter
because he sent a package he was from
the St Lawrence Atlantic railroad I
don't know if he was able to get in but
he would be able to further explain the
operational side of it and with that I
will um
um glad to answer any questions Mr chair
thank you are there are there
questions yes pleas thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question
um
who determines that the matching funds
from the uh from the railroad are
exact unfortunately I didn't hear compl
questions what I was trying to know if
it's my
up yeah um who
determined uh that the railroad spent
exactly the Max Fund what was received
from the
state that's a good qu question
representative that's why the Department
of Transportation supervises it and and
we have a full accounting of of our
money and the state's money and in fact
I wanted to bring up that in the capital
budgets and it's not in the bill uh but
the capital budget oversight committee
gets a report every uh every six months
of what money has been spent so that the
capital budget oversight committee gets
a chance to look at did the state how
much the state paid and how much the
railroad paid it's all accounted
for question and I would be glad to show
you show you the last last uh fiscal
last meeting of the capital budget
committee and the documents that we that
were submitted by the St Lawrence
Atlantic
pleas did I understand you correctly
saying that this if this deal passes and
is fully funded that it would finish the
rebuilding of the line
representative that is that this fully
funding this would complete the
refurbishing of the line uh to um to the
Vermont to through nor Trafford again
this rail has been here probably I'm
told 80 years again we sent a packet if
you I think you can see the old Rail and
the new rail but it's been there since
at least 80 maybe 90
you yeah m is Charles Hunter available
next will not see Mr
Hunter we'll uh we'll come back to Mr
Hunter uh is there anything else Paul
you wanted to say this point time no I'm
I'm completing I do see Mr Hunter's uh
name on the bottom she just has to
unmute thank you thank you Mr chair and
committee good morning everybody uh
thanks for having us Paul you did a
great summary of our project one thing I
would like to add on how the project is
funded St Lawrence and Atlantic railroad
actually pays for everything up front so
we in coordination with New Hampshire DT
we put out an RFP to order the materials
and award the Construction contract and
then we actually pay for everything UPF
front and then we're we are um
submitting for reimbursement with Dot
and they reimburse us the 50 cents on
the dollar uh any cost overrun are on
the St Lawrence and Atlantic railroad
we've done a really good job on these
other projects and managing these and
getting them in um on or under budget
and uh I really can't stress enough that
this is the last link it's really the
missing link to complete this uh project
I've been around this railroad since
1995 um we've done a lot of work in
Maine um up in Quebec to get this line
um completed so this this is really
everyone thank
you are there any are there any
Hunter seeing none thank you for your
testimony sir thank you very much the
chair would like to recognize David
Campbell excuse me David Campbell former
chair of Public Works
go honorable huh thank you
uh to see you please your testimony let
here thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee I'm David Campbell I'm an
attorney and lobbyist for the New
Hampshire North Coast railroad which I
who I represented for 34 years always a
pleasure to virtually even virtually
appear before uh my old committee um uh
I'm testifying in favor of HP
1222a first thing I want to do is
Express the Gratitude of the New
Hampshire North Coast each of the last
two Capital budgets 2017
2019 uh the state of appropriated
$900,000 in each of those budgets to be
matched um by the railroad those
projects were completed the following
year uh 2018 and 20 the 2020 U project
was was completed in December on time on
schedule in spite of covid uh it's made
a huge
difference and and I can't stress enough
there are 603 Shortline railroads in the
uh United States I remember that because
of the number um 603 but there there's
class three and um there dozens of class
one and class two railroads which are
the bigger ones the main lines these all
exist these these railroads only exist
because of the private Public
Partnerships between the federal and
state governments and and these rail
roads um the infrastructure costs are
just tremendous and to keep it uh keep
the trains rolling it it requires u a
Cooperative effort I I presented uh to
you um
PowerPoint presentation which I'm not
going to go through but it's it's
self-explanatory I'll just hit a few
highlights uh the North Coast railroad
is a 42 M Shortline railroad that runs
between um Rollinsford and goes up
through summersworth Rochester Leb and
Maine it cuts through for about a
quarter mile Milton Wakefield and up to
oopy it's part of the old Conway Branch
we've been hauling Freight for more than
150 years uh the main the main um
Freight is concrete sand that goes about
two thirds of it goes to to Boston
another third goes to Rochester propane
is the main thing that comes in goes to
Eastern Propane at their facility and we
do a lot of we run some steel too out of
out of Maine it goes to O is offloaded
and trucked over to Maine the um there's
a picture in the PowerPoint presentation
of of the transloading facility that
Services the the sand on the left and
the propane on the right um as has been
discussed you know one of the main
benefits of of shortland railroads
Freight railroads is they uh is they
take they dramatically increase fuel
efficiency decrease carbon emissions uh
because they take heavy truck trips off
the highways um New Hampshire's current
Freight volume eliminates 37,000 heavy
tractor trailer or tanker trips each
year um it has a and and that and that
just improves safety fuel efficiency but
really has a huge impact on uh on
maintenance of the roads taking that all
that that heavy traffic off the roads uh
helps helps extend their life and
reduces the maintenance costs of the
roads um nhn spends uh 350,000 to a
million dollars per year and and like
the St Lawrence in Atlantic we've had an
ongoing Capital project which just got a
big shot in the arm this past this past
year uh in the sense that we uh we
applied for a in the past we've had
tiger grants which open up the north of
the line but we just got approved last
October for a Federal grant which
allowed for 100 um I'm sorry $4.5
million in federal money we still
haven't signed the grant yet but we're
working on that um that's going to be a
four-year project and it it requires $2
million in matching funds from the North
Coast we're also getting $100,000 in
matching money from the U from a
contribution from the largest customer
Eastern
Propane
um but we still have an an issue that we
have not addressed and while we we'd be
looking at probably significantly less
money than is in the bill we we need to
start addressing the Urgent concern we
have over our our bridges our biggest
our biggest and most dangerous problem
is is was a Haven Hill bridge and I show
in the pictures if you saw it uh this
thing has had so many accidents 11 feet
tall even the sign is is is damaged from
trucks hitting it uh in the photos I
show you there's it shows the the bridge
and it's uh and on the right hand side
you can see a truck that went through it
and it was demolished no one was hurt
thankfully but the truck was demolished
and the bridge was hit you know that
that's a kind of catastrophic accident
that could shut down the bridge and
obviously cause uh damage to to to uh
property and life uh we have a bunch of
other Bridges I show show the bridges
and show some of the issues um
you know what we're looking for in this
capital budget round because of our
financial constraints both from the
tiger Grant uh and our budget
maintenance cycle you can only do so
much in a year what we're asking for is
um going be a significant lesser amount
but we would start to like addressing of
these Bridge issues over the next uh uh
15 years uh there's 33 bridges on the on
the nhn line 24 of them are owned by the
nhn and uh we are hopeful that we could
ask this uh this committee and through
the capital budget cycle to uh to make
some kind of modest U contribution to
our be beginning a a real big project
which is taking care of the bridges that
Haven Hill bridge by the way is taken
care of in the tiger Grant but it's the
only I mean in the the Chrissy Grant but
it's the only it's the only U Bridge
that's that's being addressed we do have
yearly reports the the railroad is safe
but if if we don't address these ongoing
maintenance issues deferred maintenance
issues uh we'll have problems in the
future so that concludes my testimony
I'd be happy to answer any questions of
the
committee thank you are there questions
Mr
Campbell see seeing none thank you thank
you thanks to see you all always good
seeing you here even virtually the uh we
have no other uh no other people signed
up to testify at this
time
so I will call the call the Committee
hearing
close and since we have a couple of
minutes I would like to call the
representative Mills you have any
motion I do Mr
chair I
move to retain house bill 122a I second
that motion Mr chairman just been moved
and seced that the committee retain
House Bill
discussion
see no hands raised for the
R uh the cour will call the
rooll thank you Mr
I representative Mills votes
yes representative
Yes representative Newton
yes representative blazing
yes represent boards is not here
representative kazinski
yes I am
boards represent yes I was here for the
you your vote is what representative Bo
yes thank you
I have that okay what you say I heard
you part representative
kolansky
casel representative cier yes
representative Edgar
hi representative evil yes
representative Jack
yes representative abot yes
representative
fauler
yes representative
Newman
grassy
yes representative
Peterson
query yes
representative
bunker
yes vote is
210 and with a vote of 21 to Z the bill
will be retained in the committee thank
you Mr
cler the time being 10 o' we be Ral log
we will hear House Bill five
with
um a capital appropriation for the
digitization and preservation of certain
New Hampshire supreme court records and
the chair would call on the prime
sponsor representative abon who is in
the room with us uh thank you Mr chair
uh for the record of State ripat brammy
Rockingham 19
stratum I'm here to introduce House Bill
595 as you heard I was contacted uh by
New Hampshire Supreme Court Justice
Marcone who is a my constituent in
stratum and who asked me to file this
bill for the
court she indicated to me that $2
million was required to restore records
going back to the mid 18
1800s and this was based on uh that
dollar estimate it's based on a
comprehensive study that they had done
uh over the last year or so my early
response to her was why not just make
this part of the capital request within
Judiciary she told me at the time uh in
speaking to her that state offici state
officials including Charlie alling
housee Commissioner of administrative
services that given the records were in
a building not in their in the Court's
Jurisdiction that a bill should be filed
I mean not have that 100% correct uh
it's some it was a jurisdictional issue
and that's why uh that he suggested that
a u Bill a bill be uh filed uh may I ask
the the chair if is is uh Charlie
allenhouse on the list no I did reach
out to him to to suggest that he testify
know oh yes okay so before I finalized
the bill I reached out to some of the
senior members of the House and
Senate um representative Ken Wier and
Senator Bradley and and senator
delandro who all are co-sponsors of this
bill but in my conversations with uh
Senator Bradley he suggested because of
the co virus that we we start slow with
this and uh ask for
250,000 Year One 500,000 year two and
then the remainder 1.25 million in year
three that's the way the bill reads
currently uh the bill also uh allows
bonding uh
Authority so Mr chair uh I uh justice
Marone uh tried to send on the nor on
the on the website that uh the report uh
she was going to try to break it up in
the meantime I I forwarded you a copy of
the report to share with the and we did
get a copy of that will be file the enre
report but will all
members they got invol yeah may I
suggest it's it's a long report and we
all get a lot of stuff as legislators I
would suggest just if you very least
just read the uh executive summary I
think it' be helpful is to the
background on this so but anyway um um
thank you all thank you Mr chair and
I'll take questions but I think Justice
Marcone is signed up I would suggest
that you hear from her next but you call
obviously but I'll take a question or
two but I think Justice Marone will do a
better job answering it than I will any
questions from members of the committee
for
representative see
none thank you for your testimony thank
you Mr chair chair would like to call on
here thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee um when I was appointed
to the court in
2017 shortly after my arrival I became
the library judge and the Li Library
judge is the liaison to the king Law
Library which is the only Public Law
Library in the state it is a state
facility if you will our building the
Supreme Court Building at Charles do
Drive is um under the offices of
administrative services and the New
Hampshire Law Library while we oversee
it is its own sort of Standalone um
facility providing um legal resources to
the public um my second surprise was
down in the basement of the building
since it was built 50 years ago and I
don't know where the records were before
that but we have these casebooks
starting in
1849 coming forward to
1977 after
1977 case files were kept in a more
traditional filing manner but these case
books what they used to do in the olden
days was and particularly as the Supreme
Court Justices Road circuit even they
would take the notes of the judge the
exhibits the Deeds whatever was provided
in the case the lawyer pleadings stitch
them into books and that was their
method of preservation so these books
are fascinating but they contain um
different types of Old Paper different
types of inks they're very archival in
what is there some contain writings of
famous figures some not so famous and um
they sit on shelves in our basement
which
is nicely secure and dry so far but
these are not being preserved in any
type of um archival manner plus they are
not as accessible to the public for
example Mary Baker Eddie there was some
recent litigation
lawyers came to research some prior
litigation in the 1800s and with white
gloves they're you know pulling through
these documents because they're not
online they're not accessible so in
actually
2018 uh Mary sur's our librarian and I
think she's teed up to testify also had
the um Northeast documents Center do a
review of these books and that's the
report that you have and when you look
at page 20 9 it breaks the um books into
three segments the oldest being the most
fragile and the most in need of
attention at this point in time and then
obviously the second set a little bit
different the third set more current and
in need of less immediate attention so
my um Quest was to start this process
and it can be done a book at a time um
to get the books digitized that will
involve disbonding them digitizing the
record so that it is online searchable
and we don't have to um access the
record and then preserving the artifact
because again some of these are
historical documents that we don't want
to destroy at the same time we need to
retrofit space in the basement climate
controlled so that it can um house the
um the the uh preserved records so it's
a big project the digitizing and the
preservation is the $2 million and my
goal and with uh representative of
ramy's help is to get it started I've
been in touch with ran berford at the
New Hampshire archives they can store
but they can't they don't have the
bandwidth to um preserve I've been in
touch with the New Hampshire um
Historical Society they are aware and
face similar challenges with their old
documents I've spoken with commissioner
Arling house and also
um uh Mary sherles has been in touch
with the New Hampshire library so um
we've got all the folks in the
Historical Library business aware of
this project and we've been able to draw
from them um some of their
experience that being said the
renovation of the building would be some
that would fall in the court um capital
budget process but in terms
of Court's capital budget is kind of
like the highway plan it's a
longstanding prioritization of building
and Facilities um needs in the court
buildings that some are owned by the
judicial branch some by the state but
this project is not intended to
interfere with that
longstanding um prioritization of Court
facilities so this is a bit as
representative abramy said neither fish
nor foul because we straddle um sort of
two different branches of government um
I did also meet with the joint
legislative historical committee last
spring before Co shut things down and
they were supportive of this project as
it dovetailed with some of the documents
that were discovered in the state house
renovation so um and they were the ones
that suggested a capital appropriation
and that's kind of how we got here today
to you so I am happy to answer questions
um again the process here is to get this
project off the ground so that we can
start preserving the um most fragile and
thank you
justice questions
representa thank you thank you P Justice
for taking my question um can you give
me some feel uh I have not read to your
report U what number of documents 1849
through
1977 not to the number but is it
thousands of documents or is it hundreds
of
documents I'll just
group one is 167 volumes so that is 1849
into the
1890s each volume and I've been giving
tours so anyone who wants to come over
and see these things they're fascinating
at least to me who likes old things um
each volume has couple hundred pages of
stitched in documents and some of those
documents are odd sizes they get folded
in so um there
are 167 volumes in group one
253 volumes in group two
213 volumes in group three and again
each volume has um a number of pages in
and if you turn when you get a chance to
group The entitle the entire um project
is approximately
620,000
Pages at
page thank thank you if I could so I
understand the digit dig digitizing the
documents I understand that process did
I did I hear or did I miss that the
archiving part of that for now is making
the room um more uh acceptable for
documents going forward are you actually
going to look then uh then to do
something to the pro to the documents to
reserve them better the project um the
room is I will say the third um part
that is the actual building renovation
is a third aspect that I'm looking
elsewhere um for funding the
the restoration and digitization project
has two parts so the
62,000 Pages at 175 is the
digitization and that's about a million
the preparation treating and
rehousing of the documents so that's the
archival part that's an additional
million so the 2 million involves both
the restoration and preservation
and then the
digitization thank thank you for your
time y any other questions
representative good morning Madam
Justice what where are the U where and
how are the documents going to be stored
in the interim if the building project
ends up being the last part of
this um currently they are they the
documents are on shelves in an area of
the B basement that is not the same as
the room that would be um renovated and
I'm hoping and of course the I believe
the um documents will be going offsite
to Northeast document uh Conservation
Center so a we can renovate the space
which is not the same space they're in
currently while they sit where they are
the other point is some of them will be
going off site to be
preserved and will they
restore sorry will they store them while
the construction's going on if there had
to be storage I think yes um again
the and I should and I can send over a
map of the Supreme Court basement which
I have but where they are now is not
where the construction would be
happening so they could stay where they
are where they've been luckily safe for
50 years um no leaks um while the
construction's going on in another part
of the uh
basement thank you very much any further
questions I see no hands raised from
our members who are attending
electronically thank you very much for
your testimony thank you to the
committee I have one other uh who has
signed up to speak a Mr John Lewis and
commissioner Arley house I see your hand
him Mr
Le you could
identify
yourself hello hi you're you're good if
you could identify yourself yes I'm John
Lewis uh let me start my video so you
can see me I uh I'm a retied superior
court judge and uh after I retired one
of the things that I embarked to do was
to write a law review article about the
Claremont cases and so I proceeded to
try to find out where the pertinent
records were uh for that that case which
is a historical case extremely important
uh and it's actually relatively recent
uh the major decisions that I was
focused on were in
1993 and
1997 and uh I found that when I went to
the Supreme Court I went down to that
wonderful basement that Justice Hans mon
Corney just talked to you about and
found some records there uh to be able
to work with but to my shock found that
many records were not available and in
fact the marac Superior Court couldn't
even find their
records uh finally after a lot of uh
constructive squeaky realism on my part
and others uh we did find them somewhere
uh and were able to put them together in
some sort of sensible way and I was able
to finish my law review article uh which
uh uh
is one example of how sometimes when you
write when you have the records to look
at you can really make a an impact on a
historical understanding uh of important
cases which remain uh important uh in
terms of our current uh issues and
problems so that's that got me involved
in wondering just what are we doing with
regard to our records and I I have been
in discussions with uh the Supreme Court
and just and Justice Hans Marone who's
been wonderful in in this in this effort
uh to try to get us more sensitive to
this and I'm I am a member of the New
Hampshire Supreme Court
society and uh the bar is also
interested in this uh and I'm a member
of a committee on the New Hampshire
Supreme Court society called the
judicial case history preservation
committee
and we're in the process of uh
uh surveying the bar to try to
identify uh the most
importanta cases in New Hampshire
history that have impacted on our jurist
prudence and we're going to be providing
a report to Justice Hans Marone about
that so as she does her work uh will be
able to highlight and focus on uh those
important cases we have have a whole
slew of historically important cases
throughout our history going back to the
Dartmouth College case and all sorts of
cases afterwards so um I I really
support this effort I think it's well if
you went down to the B the basement of
the New Hampshire Supreme Courts you
would see uh that they do the best they
can but the records are
not wellmaintained
and uh we're I'm only talking about
1993 I really think digital Tas digital
tasing of of these records is extremely
important and not just from a historical
point of view uh because many of these
cases uh rear their heads uh for your
consideration as well and for your
understanding of them and they're not
simple the CL on cases a perfect example
and and uh so I urge you to support this
bill I'm really pleased that it's being
done on a peac meal basis uh I really uh
applaud Justice Hans Mor conone for her
efforts here and I I hope you will
support her as well so thank you for
listening to
me thank you are there any questions
from members of the
committee to Mr leis
if not I just have if they be rhetorical
Mr Lewis as you surveyed the bar if you
ask them if they help to fund this
effort or
not I I didn't quite hear that could you
repeat
that I I said as you surveying the bar
have you roached any members of the bar
about helping to fund this preservation
effort uh I H I have not yet done that
we're we're up a stage in fact we're
going to be meeting later today where
we're sending out a email to three or
four selected bar people in in various
areas of law in which we're going to ask
them uh to identify in their areas of
law uh five to 10 cases that they think
are really
impactful and in the course of writing
that email we're going to be sensitizing
them as well the Justice H to this bill
that you're considering and I just know
from the reception we got in the New
Hampshire Supreme Court society when we
started discussing this that that
Society is made up of many very uh
experienced and competent and good
lawyers uh and judges and all of them
were extremely supportive of this effort
uh I'll just tell you I sat for a good
deal of time in straford county and and
they used to have their records very
much like uh just as Hans Maroney uh
described the Supreme Court Records in
these little binders uh and there were
occasions in my 12 years as a judge
where I had to go back to look at an old
case and sometimes even to the 1850s and
60s and boy oh boy did I have to be
careful when I open these binders that
the records wouldn't just disintegrate
in my hand
uh as I was dealing with them and these
required what's before us on the Supreme
Court Records please we have there are
only three people to sign up I have
much any other questions I see
none if we could promote commissioner
Arling
so he can
speak
you
commissioner hi can you hear me we can
hear you oh perfect uh this is Charlie
Arling housee I'm the commissioner of
administrative services and it's my
pleasure to join you this morning
following your distinguished panels um I
would say oh somebody wants me to start
my video hang on
typically people don't want to see me
and they're happy not to but here I am
um I was going to say something uh
profound and I've now forgotten it um oh
I would say this I would think the
Supreme Court has done an excellent job
taking has done a better job taking care
of the records in their basement than I
would have in mine but I'm not sure
that's the standard that we're
particularly looking for but um um they
should probably preserve records we
should give them the ability to preserve
records in a way that is superior to my
ability to preserve creamed corn um just
a thought um why is this happening this
way is a key question I I want to make
sure you don't think that we don't
support the project or think it's a good
idea at all um uh I was over and and uh
justice Marcone gave me a tour of the
basement which I was very interesting
and the documents are um Court
facilities enter the capital budget
typically um or always I guess as a
result of the deliberations of a court
accreditation committee which some of
your members have been on I'm pointing
but you can't see who I'm pointing at um
but
um they uh debate the terms of the
building and then our capital budget
requests through administrative services
and our Bureau of Court facilities ay
administered by um the excellent Sarah
Lineberry as most of you know um puts
those requests together this isn't that
the Supreme Court record are not part of
the um operational standard of Court
facilities um as determined by a
comprehensive fully constituted
committee it's a separate thing doesn't
make it a bad idea makes it it's
actually I think it's a really good idea
um they're terrific records that we're
that are in danger of one bad snowstorm
or a state building leaking which
occasionally happens you may know um uh
away but it's presented this way um we
are agnostic at administrative services
on whether it's part of the capital
budget or Standalone legislation I think
this is a perfectly reasonable approach
but um you may decide to to merge it um
I would just say I think it's an
important project and and we're very
supportive of Justice marone's efforts
on
it and will no doubt help thank you
have I have one that is just procedural
do you know commissioner since your
department works closely with the
governor's office on developing the
capital budget that he will present to
us whether or not this project has been
presented to the governor as part of
that discussion it it it was not the
capital budget hearings were in July
virtually very much like this as you
might recall um and it was I don't think
that I don't think it was actually fully
formed at that time and so this is not
not something that I think he's been
looking at I don't know if his people
know otherwise but um I suspect that
request okay thank you any other
questions from members of the committee
either here or virtually seeing none
thank you commissioner thank you for
having
me
recognize Miss C if you
yourself can you hear
okay I'm I'm sorry I don't have a micro
uh
video um yes I'm the register of deeds
at the marrat County registry of
deeds and we have subject our records to
uh such a process it was costly it took
a long time um fortunately we have a
budget for that but what I wanted to
talk about was um
email and um if you don't have it in
it or let me summarize it um summarize
please okay
the where the historic record the court
record is in my opinion as a keep of
land records um where it's most
important is in the area of um research
and litigation involving land ownership
and
usage um for three reasons
um first of
all land records
are they go back quite a bit in time so
for instance someone could have granted
an easement in
perpetuity 100 200 years ago
and we our office does not always have
those
records we have what only whatever
records have been filed by by someone by
a person um and then we keep that we are
a registry we are not um an official
source so when people do um title
searches
uh prepare for litigation about land
they are more likely to go back very far
um to the first
um to to
the the first known ownership or
instance where um the problem occurred
and the second thing is that land
ownership devolves from common
law it is less a sub process of
legislation than other forms of Law and
so every time there's a case that has to
do with land that becomes part of the um
that becomes part of the law because
such cases provide
precedence to other
cases and then the last thing is that
right now um um
research has been made more
difficult so for instance a someone who
wants to develop a large tract of land
may need to do a lot of
research and we are we will be their
first source of um of
review but when there are challenges
they will have to go back not only to
our records but to the court records and
some of these may be old now all of our
records are
online going back to our first in the
mid
1800s and we've
done a pretty good job
um but we have a much smaller body of
Records um and we have a funding source
for them too and every year when we go
our
budget the
um the legislative committee if we could
keep it on the court records and not
your own I would appreciate
it sorry I can't hear you I I said if
you could keep your testimony directed
at the court records and not your own uh
County records would be appreciated okay
um well um
that's it thank you very much um and I
also for the for everybody's edification
I think all the members of the committee
got it we received a similar uh
testimony from Kelly Monahan who is
president of the New Hampshire registers
of deeds in full support of HB
595 for the same reasons that Miss rean
um just outlined
there any questions
for
the may I add one
thing
um I had received word from Coos County
um that they were going to testify about
how important it was that records be
available um online as you know Coos
County is um somewhat isolated it to the
court records it would be
appreciated
yes that's it thank you
yep there are two more hands raised and
I would ask that when we call upon you
if it is new testimony it would be
appreciated but try to limit um
repetition from what has already been
said by either Justice Marone or the
others who have testified first one up
right welcome to Public Works and
highways miss
and good morning can you hear me we've
got
yet my name is Mary surles I'm the law
librarian at the New Hampshire Supreme
Court and uh I'm doing I swear I will be
brief I will add just one thing I wanted
to emphasize the scope of these records
and of the various uses that um they are
they are used by used for um these
records include not only cases that have
published opinions but also any case
that was filed at the super Court the
briefs the pleadings correspondence
sometimes from the judges and there are
no other records of these these cases
that did not result in published
opinions so these are very unique and
valuable records that we have the other
thing I wanted to emphasize is the scope
of the uses genealogists use these
records to research family history we've
had law schools ask for copies of these
older records um just as Hance Marone
mentioned the current litigation but we
also um have had we also have a
researcher who is writing a history of
the mount Cog Railway and is looking at
the litigation that was involved with
that so these are go far beyond just a
history of the court system or just the
legal profession but speak to the
history of New Hampshire and her
citizens that's all I have thank you
very
much thank you very much are there any
questions from members of the committee
that are either in the room or attending
remotely seeing
none I thank you for your testimony it
is
appreciated before I close this out I
see no other hands raised for House Bill
we are starting a little late on the
next one I do want to point out that
there is written testimony in support of
um House Bill
595 from attorney mlin from the capital
insights Group which I think all of the
members of the committee um received and
will be in the file seeing no
other hands raised or people signed up
to speak I will close the hearing on
much and the time being Beyond
10:30 I
will uh open the hearing on House Bill
305 and call upon the sponsor
representative Horan to testify
there thank you very much thank you very
much Mr chair I I hope you can hear me
and um we can identify yourself
representative organ yes my name is
representative Timothy Horgan I um
represent straford County district 6
which is the towns of Durham and Madbury
and um also off of the straford uh the
spaling Turnpike exit 6 is my exit um I
go this is not the New Jersey
legislature anyway
hb35 well it's an exact repeat of HB
1363 which uh was assigned to the
transportation committee rather than the
Public Works committee if I call
correctly and actually um passed
committee unanimously was passed on a
Voice vote in the Full House and then it
uh this was uh this is in late February
and then in March he sent it to the
Senate and for what and for um as we all
know things were kind of disrupted back
then and this is one of the bills that
got uh lost in the shuffle and the
Senate tabled it but it's
uh it deals with pretty simple bill it
just simplifies the existing law
relating to those um blue signs which
appear short ly for limited access
Highway exits which say things like
attractions Exit 32 so and um the state
owns those signs of course but uh and
The Operators of attractions and uh
motorist services pay yearly fees to
have their businesses advertised on the
signs and um just a couple of years ago
we uh contracted with a business which
uh administers the program for the state
the signs are not particularly Well's
not
inexpensive but it's it's it's uh very
beneficial for both uh businesses and
the motorists um and the program cost to
State nothing in fact I think it
actually makes a small profit um and um
I know you send me an email asking me I
sent a page of written testimony there's
like long history behind this but um and
I want to any I left a lot of the
history out but basically right now
under existing law there's restrictions
on how many signs be erected north of
conquer on IED 9 or i93 as opposed from
the Massachusetts border to conquered um
so right now south of conquer the do and
um and contractor I guess put up as many
additional motorist services and
traction signs as they please if there's
a demand for more signs
um north of conquer we can do additional
traction signs can be W if needed but
only one set of motorist services signs
allowed even if there's demand for more
signs and uh well first of all the teach
north of south of conquer that sounds
simple but actually causes a lot of
certain amount of confusion in my part
of the state we have the Spalding
Turnpike which at the
33 mile limited north south limit
accessa which doesn't go particularly
near Massachusetts it's 12 miles from
the border and it goes up to to Milton
um so it's really unclear where in the
Spalding turnpike north of conquer is
there is a conquer is a control City on
the exit from my exit exit 6 but um
actually conquered it conquered is due
west of the over so um so anyways this
is a this is just a very simple bill
it's a pro pro business and PR motorist
bill because um as I said they um
motorists like these signs because they
can see what's visible what's going to
be available at the next exit and the
businesses like it because it it drives
more business to the state and also um
businesses especially benefit from it
are state liquor stores which contribute
a lot of money to the state coffers and
then also uh and also gas stations and
uh restaurants also pay a lot of taxes
to the state so um I think I think um I
think we should uh finish what we
started uh started last year pass it to
um the committee this was Transportation
last time but it's in your committee
this time and um send it off you know
send it on its way and um I hope uh Hing
hope we get this uh passed and signed by
the governor pretty soon so that's
that's um that's my testimony I'd be
happy to take any question questions so
there may be others who can speak more
to the technical details of it are there
any questions from members of the
committee for represent orgon either
those in the room or those
attending see
N I would call on the next person who
signed up um Mr Henry
bote
hry okay thank you um thank you Mr
chairman uh and members of the committee
uh for the record uh my name is Henry
veu and I'm here on behalf of the New
Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association um our association uh
supports this bill uh we were involved
uh when this original
statute uh was created I don't know a
dozen years or so ago um and uh there
was some concern among folks about uh um
logos on the on the signs uh north of
conquered and the grand bargain back
then was all right let's let's do it uh
conquered South uh so this bill here
basically just strikes out the language
of the prohibition of the Lo goes on the
main line of the highway um so they're
they're on the they're as as you get off
the exits uh on the main
lines um up north um you can see the
logos uh you know the Common Man or
whatever it is uh you know restaurant at
at the bottom of the exit ramp you'll
see them uh but those logos are
prohibited on the on the mainline of the
highway so a mile before the exit uh and
of course they're limited uh to uh those
restaurants and lodging properties that
are located near the exit so this is not
for restaurant that's several miles down
the road the purpose of them obviously
is uh uh motorist Service uh to let them
know uh that there is something at the
exit so um I'll I'll stop there uh just
wanted to let the uh committee know that
the restaurant Lodging Association does
support the
belt are there any any questions Mr V
from members of the committee either
here or those attending
virtually see no hands raised thank you
for your testimony Mr
V and final speaker on this bill um Mr
Bill Lambert uh from the Department of
Transportation
good unmute yourself there you go all
right good morning everyone it's good to
see everybody again even if it's just in
a gallery on screen uh and thank you Mr
chairman and for the record my name is
Bill Lambert I'm the state tra uh
traffic engineer for the New Hampshire
Department of Transportation I did s
submit um testimony a written testimony
I hope you all were able to get that
it's essentially just a a brief overview
or background of of the um specific
service sign uh signing program as it's
called by the um manual and uniform
traffic control devices which is
published by Federal Highway um so I
won't I won't repeat that uh one thing
that I would add is that the current um
the current bill was was kind of
prompted by action we took in around 20
2013 uh when the New Hampshire
Department of Transportation uh adopted
the attractions category uh the specific
service signs that that came some years
after the original food gas lodging
camping uh and when we had the food gas
lodging camping uh starting in the 90 in
1995 we only put the the specific logos
on the ramps and we had generic symbols
for those four categories that we could
put out on the highway to let people
know that those Services were available
and then they could find out what the
specific choices were when they were on
the ramp when we adopted the attractions
category it was was harder to do that
because there isn't a generic symbol for
attractions uh so that that prompted
those signs to go on the main line uh
which then prompted the bill to add uh
the other categories on the mainline
south of conquer uh and we've defined
north of conquer uh at least for our
program to be um I want to say exit
three on 89 exit 17 and 93 and all of
the divided section of of the Spalding
TR Pike through rooch Chester uh the
extension of this balding turnpike north
of there where it goes to two lanes uh
is not included in the
program um so it there's a history with
it there specific service signs I
noticed representative Horan mentioned
the term advertising Federal Highway
does not consider them to be advertising
they're a directional signing to for a
specific Motor Service um but the
reality is that most of the participants
and a lot of the public consider it as
advertising uh as indicated by
representative Horgan's testimony um
it's popular for most of the folks that
are in it uh we've had some concern
about the cost uh of our contract
Service um we we don't make a profit on
it uh we do get um some payback out of
their um the revenue that they generate
but it essentially offsets our cost to
administer the program we are not
allowed by Statute to um to generate
Revenue out of it uh just to offset the
cost of the program so that self
supporting with that I'd be happy to
take any
questions
um representative FL okay thank you Mr
chairman um the prime sponsor represent
poran mentioned that that this program
now makes a small profit for the state
can you comment I I assume is that a
profit for the highway fund thank you no
like I just said we he did say that uh
we we get money back from the contractor
that that manages the program um but
we're not allowed by Statute to generate
Revenue we're only allowed to offset the
costs to make it self-supporting uh so
they're essentially paying us um back to
the highway fund our cost to administer
the program so we've got probably one
and a half positions of persons that are
primarily responsible for outdoor
advertising control um and and most of
their time is spent on the logo program
what we call a logo program so they're
essentially just paying that back plus
other administrative
cost okay thank you thank you and follow
on to that if I may um when you say that
they are reimbursing or um for the
administrative cost is the state
recovering all of the administrative
costs that this program is costing
through this
contract um I would say initially no the
way that the contract was written was
that they uh and it was a
a u request for proposals we had one
response to that proposal and their
proposals that they would pay us I think
it's 50,000 a year uh or 5% whichever
was greater so as their program is
started we're getting that 50,000 which
doesn't quite offset our direct cost um
but it does um have the ability as they
add more signs and generate more Revenue
over time U that 5% uh number should get
um representative
eel I mute yourself yeah um good to see
you Mr Lambert um I don't know about
others I don't seem to have your
testimony I don't know if it would have
come from you or or Kathleen so if this
was covered in there could you um
refresh our memories on the uh Genesis
of the exclusion of the uh signs from
the northern part of the state I'm I I'm
remembering that part of the concern
there was to keep the North Country a
little more free of of signage but maybe
you can um help us and if you could
resend your testimony that would be
great thank
you yeah I'd be happy too I'm not sure
how I I submitted the testimony on the
link that was provided I'm not sure how
that gets distributed um
uh chairman Graham I'd be happy to send
it to you or if there's somebody else I
can do that to uh it's all new me and I
will get it make sure it gets out to
everybody all right I appreciate that
and it's good to see you again as well
representative EO uh the Genesis of the
Restriction of the uh the area north of
conquer and in my written testimony uh I
I indicated that when the program was
first adopted by us in 1995 there were
two people that were involved then in
developing our administrative roles that
were involved with the program kind of
on the legislative side and our staff
side for a lot of years and one of those
was representative Chandler from
Bartlett and he was adamantly opposed to
uh a lot of blue signs on the side of
the highway especially up in the North
Country um in in around the mid teens uh
there was there was a bill moving
forward um not the one that was
eventually passed that added the
mainline s self are conquered but the I
think the session before that and kind
of as an aside representative Chandler
said something to the effect of I don't
care what you do self have conquered U
so that led to language in the bill uh
that that allowed the science to be on
the mainline south of conquer um and
that's the way it is now um from my
perspective there are certainly rural
interchanges North have conquered and
some of them South are conquered where
you don't have a lot of of the the food
gas lodging camping Services uh camping
is not really going to be at a whole lot
of the the southern ones anyway um but
there are certainly um hot spots um say
Plymouth
Tilton
um certainly linkoln Woodstock Littleton
um Lebanon places like New London uh
where you're famili familiar with where
there are a lot of services and really
there's places where the rural sections
of the highway what the program was made
for so that people that that needed to
break from driving I could get off and
comfortably find services that they
could depend
on hope that answers your
question thank you any further
questions any the members here or not
thank you for your testimony Mr Lambert
if you could send that out we have the
history of where where this came and
where we're going all right we'll
do um
seeing
nobody else either signed up or with
their hand raised on House Bill
305 I will call the meeting to an
end and we will move on to House Bill
74 sorry for the delay um for those who
have been waiting on House Bill 74
which
is and to
thees and I would like to call upon the
there you
are
yourself okay thank you can everyone
hear me yes okay thank you very much um
I submitted my written testimony
yesterday but I'll enter it into the
record and also for the record uh my
name is representative Rosemary rung I
represent Hillsboro 21 which is the town
of
marac um many of you who have been on
this committee for years knows that this
isn't the first marac to bill that
you've seen uh many bills regarding the
Turnpike tolls in miramac have come
before this Committee in one way or
another they have sought relief from the
unfair burden on miramac residents who
have shouldered a disproportional
responsibility for the cost of the ever
turnpike's operation and maintenance
this unfairness continues with plans to
install open road tolling in marac just
north of exit 8 um that was included in
the transportation Omnibus Bill that was
passed last summer by the house I ask
the committee to return to the basics of
what a Turnpike is as you consider
consider this bill turnpikes are user
funded drivers that use a Turnpike pay
for it to be fair and Equitable the toll
should be assessed for all users
proportionately fairness and Equity that
is what this bill is about this bill is
not about banning tolls in miramac it is
about assessing tolls where the road
gets the most use data from the New
Hampshire Department of Transportation
shows the heaviest traffic is along the
nashille corridor in fact the busiest
stretch has already been designed and
constructed to accommodate tol boo
unfortunately politics scuttled this
plan and the busiest section of the
turnpike remains free for users this is
not what a Turnpike is supposed to be so
i' I'd be happy to intro uh to um answer
any questions that you have um the the
bill is pretty simple in its language
it's really just to uh Place tools where
the there are more
users thank
you are there any questions from members
represent see none thank you for your
testimony thank you very much chair will
call
representative BL who is in the room as
a member of the
comme thank you Mr chairman um yeah so I
I'll be very brief but um just to Echo
what representative rung said obviously
for many many years the citizens of of
marac have been disproportionately
affected they practically can't move
couldn't move in the town without paying
a toll um and you know luckily some of
the tolls have been removed now and so
that's no longer the case but um marac
is not the the busiest section um nsha
is and so uh if we're going to at some
point add new tolls back in um it should
be where there is the most traffic and
not uh where the people of marac will be
disproportionately
affected are there any questions from
members of the committee uh
session if not um Representative Bob B I
[Music]
I
about Mr chairman could it be
representative Healey that you're
looking for who representative Healey
that you were looking for not Hayes
Healey um no I got a Bob Hayes Jerry
Hayes and Nancy Murphy who have signed
up to
see those are the members those are the
members of I assume the public nobody
said they were elected
official um I have two sheets of people
primarily I assume from marac who has
signed in and
support of the bill but do not wish to
uh participate by
testifying there's a long list but those
names will be entered into the
record
and I see one hand raised representative
orgon do you have something new to add
if
thank you very much Mr chair um first of
all I just wanted to say that the uh
Prime sponsor is one of the most
outstanding members of the house there's
anybody Works harder to serve the people
of her town or her or her state so this
um these exit are a severe inconvenience
for the people of marac who have to uh
you know who have to pay to get on and
off the turnpike even they just like
using it to get across town and um it's
also inconvenience for other
motorists if we could stick to what the
bill says oh sorry yes I'm get getting
there so I'm represent Timothy Horan
straford County district 6 I continue to
represent Durham and Madbury so it's an
inconvenience for other motorists too
because uh theyve were talking a minute
ago about uh motorist services and
attractions miramac has actually many of
those it's a fine community years it
does a lot more than just connect uh
Bedford to Bedford to uh to NASA and um
so I think uh you know and those
motorist services um I think they have
the blue signs on the highway and
certainly they're also like Jason to the
exit more so than many other exits so
this is an inconvenience for all
motorists and um yeah and also to boost
and general are an obsolete uh
technology we're moving towards overhead
tolling but uh we do do the overhead
tolling um you know all communities
should be treated fairly so certainly uh
marac people of marac or visitors to
marac should not have to pay more tolls
and visitors in Nashville or any the
other towns along the along the along
our limited access highways so that's
why I just wanted to chime in and say
this is a good bill so thanks thank you
any questions for representative forgan
from members of the
committee see none thank you Mr chair
Abbot who is she
on
okay
Murphy oh good morning thank you Mr
chair and honorable committee members
I'm Nancy Murphy a Marin Mack resident
um and I just wanted to say that I would
hope that you could um vote a to pass on
this bill um our March Community has
been a has shouldered a large financial
burden for the New Hampshire toll system
for a number of years and um I I think
citizens feel like we certainly um you
know are uh need need to pay our our
part uh but it seems our part continues
to uh to maybe be uh exceed that of of
other uh users of the of the tolls so um
I would ask that um you can you consider
this bill um as a relief for the town of
marac um and that um a a in the the
transportation plan a determination be
made where the usage is where that if
there's a higher usage that tolls be put
in there uh which will of course you
know help uh the state but will also
unburden marac residence so that was it
just wanted to briefly check in and and
say thank you for taking my
testimony okay thank you very much are
there any questions for The Honorable
Murphy
seeing none NE here nor
Abbott uh thank you chairman uh can
everybody hear me yes okay great uh for
the record my name is Gary Abbott I'm
the Executive Vice President of the
associated general contractors of New
Hampshire I'm we just I will tell you I
bring these bills before my board of
directors um this bill we
reviewed we had a major concern about
this bill that it kind of sets a
precedence uh when it comes to
construction planning that you would
start to file legislation if you didn't
want something thing without really
knowing the full scope as we all know
the marac tolls we also know for a long
time there was just one marac toll and
then there was going to be a circumen
highway G to be a toll in Nasher and
there's going to be a toll in Bedford
Nash didn't go it has a long history but
what we see is one of our major concerns
is it sets a precedent of communities
filing legislation with the state house
saying they don't want tolls and this
would be in my opinion or in our
association's opinion a bad precedent to
start setting it should be really
discussed as projects are proposed and
toll booths are proposed in the future
it's I also think that there's concern
of binding one legislative uh group to
another through this kind of action this
really is different than what we've seen
in the past to have an outright statute
that bans a certain thing whether it's
tolls in a community or not so I just
wanted to raise that with the committee
that that is one of the things we looked
at we know the legislature will look at
any future projects and consider those
on Case by case and the legislature over
the last few years has removed tolls
from maramax so um you know that should
be an important point but with that uh
thank you thank you for taking the time
to listen to My
Testimony thank you Mr Abbott are there
any questions of Mr Abbott from members
of the
committee I see none here and I hands
raised from our virtual members um thank
you Mr
ab and
finally
um I would like to hear from uh Victoria
Shen commissioner the Department of
ra welcome commissioner good morning Mr
chairman members of the committee for
the record Victoria Sheen commissioner
of the Department of
Transportation uh before I begin my
remarks I just want to thank the chair
for the invitation this afternoon to
speak to the committee we look forward
to talking about the roles of the
department
um in more detail uh this afternoon but
this morning I wanted to speak to the
language in the bill and just make sure
the committee understands how the
current 10-year plan process works as
commissioner of do I do not add projects
to the 10-year plan the 10-year plan
process is a three-phase process um the
first phase we work with gasset um the
governor's advisory committee on
Intermodal
transportation and then we work with the
governor and the SEC phase and then the
last phase is the legislative phase and
so as commissioner I don't have the
authority to add projects into the 10e
plan in the gaset phase that first phase
the commissioner is a non voting member
of gaset and so really um in each phase
the department is tasked with drafting a
plan on behalf of that body who is um
overseeing that phase of the process um
so it's either gaset that would
introduce a project um the governor
or the legislature um so my I just want
to make sure you understood what
authorities the commissioner of
Transportation currently has as you
reflect on the content of this bill with
respect to the location of tolls you
know where we site um a toll plaza is
legislature thank you commissioner are
there any questions of the commissioner
from members of the committee either in
the room or attending
virtually um any general questions you
have of her um not specific to this bill
we will take up this
afternoon so questions on her statements
about this
commissioner I see no one else has
signed up I see no further hands raised
at this this point I would like to close
the hearing on House Bill
74 I would ask all the committee that is
attending remotely
to um turn your cameras back on we are
about to go into executive session and
the the
speakers um Rule and guidance that you
saw in the calendar and that I have
reiterated is I have to be able to see
your face if you're um participating
much
um before we have some time so we have
one more bill that starts at 11:30 but
before we get to that point I would like
to open the executive session on B bills
that we we have before us the first bill
up in this executive session is House
Bill 595 making a capital appropriation
for the digitization and preservation of
certain New Hampshire Supreme Court
Records uh representative Mills you have
a motion I do Mr chair uh regards the
fact that this is mostly due to the
capital budget I move to retain House
Bill 595 I will second that Mr chairman
the motion has been made and seconded
that the committee retain House Bill
595 I would like to say one thing I
support this motion it is it is been the
longstanding practice of the committee
that when we have large Capital
Appropriations in $2 million believe it
or not is the large appropriation for
Capital expenditures in the capital
budget that we fundle them all into the
capital budget so that when the go uh
the governor presents his um capital
budget and the treasurer tells us what
we can afford to bond that we can look
at all of the projects at the same time
rather than just having peace meal we
have found that that has worked under
chairman
like
represent and and others we we tried to
do that
so does anybody else have anything to
say about the motion to retain House
Bill 595 Mr chairman I just like to Echo
your statements and I think this is a
very worthwhile but hopefully we can
include some money in the capital budget
for this task and maybe get the bar
association to chip in I that up so but
I I think we should retain it definitely
thank you
represent anybody else I see no hands
raised from panelists do I
no seeing none uh the clerk will call
the
role representative Muni
I clerk votes
yes representative
samaro I vote
Yes representative
Newton I vote
Yes representative blazic yes
representative boards
yes representative kazinski
yes representative
kolansky
yes representative Thompson
yes representative cludia
yes representative Edgar
hi representative eil
yes representative Jack yes
representative Abbott
yes representative fauler
yes representative
Newman
yes representative grassie
yes representative
Peterson
query
yes representative
and the chair representative Graham
votes
yes total vote is 21
Z vote being 21 to zero the motion to
retain is adopted and the bill will be
retained next up executive session on
House Bill
305 relative to motorist service signs
on limit
access
highways do I hear a motion um okay yeah
I will I will make a motion of op to
pass Mr chairman but I do have a
question do Mr Lambert testify what what
was his position did he indicate it was
informational informational only okay as
as as usual okay I'm it's a legit I the
way I gathered it was a
legislative uh prerogative to say y or n
they provide information okay all right
in this case and sometimes because
sometimes they do take a position just
for has moved on to pass on
305 is there a
second representative Jack second like
to speak to my motion please when don't
you get a chance okay thank you I
believe last term it was a different
committee the house Transportation
committee passed this bill and I believe
it went to the house was on consent
calendar passed and then we sent it the
Senate and then the pandemic hit and
they didn't do anything it was just not
one of their priorities and I think in
Reading represent corgan's testimony uh
beforehand I just think this makes sense
I think it's a it's an argue a fairness
issue I don't know that's what I think
it may make is Maybe Can't a profit but
it may help offset some of the costs
that do has of monitoring the sign and
at least it should be a break even you
know that it shouldn't be costing do
anything to put up these
signs you know uh so I feel it's
important that we pass this bill the
Full House pass it send to the sen
hopefully this time the Senate will do
the right thing thank you thank you any
further comments on the odd to pass
305 seeing none Court will call the role
and John I gu okay good yes I know I
just remember that I have to do the
writing unfortun okay
representative mononi
I clerk votes
yes representative
samaro I vote
Yes representative
Newton
yes representative blazic yes
representative
boards yes representative kazinski yes
representative kalansky
yes representative Thompson yes
representative cludia yes representative
Edgar hi representative
eel
hi representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes representative
Faulkner yes representative
Newman yes repr
representative
grassie
yes representative
Peterson
query yes
representative
bunker
yes and the chairman representative
21 to zero is the vote representative uh
thank you Mr clerk the vote being
2120 on not to pass the motion is
adopted any objection to the consent
committee seeing none it will be uh on
the consent
calendar um thank you House Bill 74
the ACT relative to maram ramp toll
plazas represent
mcon thank you Mr chairman I would like
to move itl in expedient to legislate on
House Bill
7 there a second a second from
representative Abbot has been moved and
seconded that house bill
74 um be found inexpedient to
legislate what discussion is
there any
members here or attending virtually
representative CL here yes Mr chairman
um with I appreciate the prime sponsor
and all the sponsors motivation for
putting this in if I lived in marac I'd
obviously want to do something about
this issue but I have to look at it as a
former chair Vice chair Etc I've been
around
I've got to look at the total impact on
the on the turnpike
system and it would be great you know I
think the prime sponsor mentioned about
something about putting them elsewhere
well the problem is the people in in the
area she mentioned are not wild about a
toll and I remember being here and we
tried that your entire majority of our
committee agreed to do it we brought in
the house for part of the 10e plan and
it was immediately took out you make
made your head spin I didn't figure they
they get the votes I figured it would
just be the people in the affected area
and that's basically it the problem is
no one wants a toll booth in their area
uh but it's something too it's something
that was put in before I came to this
legislature so we have to have revenue
for if we're going to have a turn plight
system if we abolish it we're still
going to have to maintain those roads
and I believe when I was in my first
term there was a similar bill that Mar m
reps put in and the and and we were told
I don't know this is true but this is in
1993 that it was going to if we
abolished all the tolls in the entire
system and granted it that's what it
aimed to do a 10cent increase in the gas
tax so and maybe that was who knows
whether that was right or not but the
point is if we abolish tolls we're still
going to have to maintain those roads
and it's going to have to come from
somewhere whether it's a turn flight
fund or or a highway fund and gas taxes
Etc no one wants to pay more on gas tax
either so with some reluctance I'm going
to vote the motion to support itl and
and maybe we can I don't know get an and
I've tried to work with past the the
town of marac on on some sort of
compromise because I can understand if I
was from that area believe me I'd want
to eliminate as many tolls and I think
now it's because of the of a bill we
passed increasing the gas tax a few
years ago or the road toll and the
governor and council's action last year
I think two out of the three tolls have
now been eliminated so we're making
making progress if you look at it from a
marac perspective I just don't think
we're there yet until we can get some
sort of agreement where we want what we
want to do with tolls whether it's open
road tolling or put them in a particular
part of the state you know that
everybody can agree upon so that's all I
have to say Thank you Mr representative
fluier representative fuler you have
your hand raised yes thank you Mr
chairman uh I just want to add I think
that if we get into judging what's fair
by what town people come
from we're never going to hear the end
of it you know we've already heard
miramac versus Nashville and it'll be
conquer versus Manchester the only fair
way to allocate the cost of the turnpike
is by how much people use it and that
ought to be our Criterion and our only
Criterion if there's an
exception for some other reason and I
know I've heard that you know we don't
want to have a exit a a toll before the
first exit because of the people coming
up to the
mall uh then it ought to be judged on
whether that has a positive impact on
the state as a whole rather than one
Town versus another because I just think
this town versus town is going to be an
forever thank
you representative
plac one of the
sponsors uh I just want to point out
this bill isn't really about Town versus
Town it is about the use so it I think
the reason why representative rung
brought up NASA versus marac is because
NASA has higher traffic it's used more
than marac so it we're not really
comparing towns we are trying to compare
usage thank
you I see no
other hands
raise from our virtual members and none
in here um
Mr clerk are we ready for the vote
on and exp meeting to legislate on House
Bill 74 we are Mr
chair representative representative
mcon
I yes representative
samaro I vote
Yes representative
Newton
yes representative BL
no representative boards
yes representative kazinski yes
representative
khansi yes representative Thompson
yes representative cluder yes
representative Edgar hi representative
evil yes representative
Jack representative Abbot yes
representative fauler yes representative
Newman
yes representative grassie
[Music]
yes
that's representative
Peterson
yes representative
representative
bunker
yes 20 to one Mr chair with a vote to 20
to one the motion of itl is
adopted this are an objection to the
consent calendar
seeing no
objection uh it will go to the consent
calendar that brings us up to our last
bill we have five minutes before it is
scheduled to be
heard um take a break remember that the
bics are
live I
just you know you just got to make sure
that you understand I have a big
you
e
I believe that's how he if not he will
correct I just
say I I murdered his name all the time I
did
that that's right yeah got the
experience
represent I see uh food and drink is
permitted at your committee
see
11:30 thank you committee members the
11:30 committee members the hour being
11:30 I would like to convene uh House
Bill
114 relative to the erection of sound
viia tberry Lane in the town of Bedford
and the chairman would recognize
representative Graham introduce the Bill
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I am representative John
Graham hillsbor District which is the
town of Bedford I bring this forward as
at the request of constituents within
the town to live along tber Lane um
tberry Lane parallels the F Turn Pipe in
the to of
Bedford it was built and the houses were
built primarily there before the fir
Pike was expanded when I was going up
the divided highway
ended at where is now exit 5 in
nashille um and you got off it then
became a two l Road all the way up to
Pittsburgh um so as the turnpike has
expanded the houses are there they are
older homes by and large um not
insulated for sound protection or the
rest uh but they run into a problem
every time that the Turn Pipe is
expanded or rebuilt and widened that
they don't meet the
density um rule under erection of sound
walls it's not enough houses along that
road even though the decb that the
actual sound that is hitting those Downs
actually does
exceed what should be done um so I bring
this forward um
and one of returning members of the
committee know we've heard this bill
before um it is a perennial issue um for
the residents of pberry Lane and hence
of the
uh representatives from Bedford so I
bring this for one of the last times it
was heard there was talk about it didn't
meet Federal Highway funding guidance
which is why you see that I am
suggesting that the cost be taken out of
ter fund since it's along the ter um but
that is up to the community to determine
where the charge would come from but I
think as a matter of working with with
the people of tberry Lane who have been
long suffering on this issue that we go
ahead and pass this bill and with that I
will try to take any questions um I
think the the apartment is
also available at the end to talk about
cost and benefits and the rest
but I will leave it at that thank you
representative Graham are there
questions for representative gr I yes
represent to you recognize um under
Grand tberry Lane where is that with
respect to uh where 101
crosses it it is essentially if you know
if you're headed south on uh the F A you
go on the underpass where Target and
um low dep are up on the H and now some
hotels up there a little bit further
it's on the right it's it's separated by
some trees essentially from the F so
it's on that side is there followup
thank
you are there are there further
questions for yes
repres uh were the houses I'm assuming
the houses are not that old that they
were built before the
turnpike by a large yes I I can't
guarantee every one of them was built
before the turnpike was widened and it
widen in the last few years as well as
we um worked on the U airport Access
Road and made additional um lanes for
that that run right by that very
area thank you further questions for
representative
gram yes
years there but there's a huge diff the
question was for those of may not have
heard it is the highway has been there
for for a longer time than what I was
talking about about the extension but
there's a huge difference between a
two-lane road um Meandering through um
marac and and others and bedord in
Manchester as opposed to a four lane
divided highway actually about six Lanes
through there right now three each
Direction with trucks and
increased traffic and all the rest so it
decades thank you represent kazinski are
there are there other members with
seeing none thank you thank
you um we are second speaker which is
all that I believe we have signed up
here
representative
SAS I apologize for Miss are you are you
present
representative
please go right can you hear me now yes
I can sir okay thank you very much uh Mr
chairman and and committee members uh I
want to say uh to begin with that I am
totally a Big supporter of sound
barriers uh when the uh do has certified
that a community or a neighborhood
deserves them in fact some of you some
of the members on this committee know
that a year ago I actually submitted a
bill uh not only to increase Highway
funding which is desperately needed but
also to set aside a small amount of that
for
annually uh taking care of our 49
locations that have been certified to
need uh sound barriers uh neighborhoods
that have uh like the neighborhood in
Portsmith have been waiting sometimes
over 30 years to get what they've been
certified to have be entitled to but
because there was a lack of funding of
it now I understand that you know uh
every neighborhood has its own unique
situation but I want to point out that
in contrast to uh the Bedford site uh
the one in in Portsmith for example
expands up to 12 Lanes of traffic in
that neighborhood and the sound is
incredible uh so there is a process that
the do has for dealing with this at
least as far as putting them on a list
of type two noise abatement projects
however the problem has always been
funding so I I am a strong supporter of
doing both funding for sound barriers
and increasing the highway funding uh
but on the other hand this bill in my
opinion and I'm a cheap skate and I'm a
fiscally conservative Democrat both
personally and publicly uh this bill is
unfunded there is no funding for it and
it's $2 million of unfund for a
worthwhile project however without a
designated source of Revenue so uh
because of that I think it's it's
inherently a questionable project uh now
I'm more than willing to offer my bill
as an amendment to this bill so that we
could get some funding for it as well as
for the highway fund however uh under
the conditions that it is right now uh I
would be opposing it and I want to point
out that the panaway manor neighborhood
that I represent is a bluecollar
neighborhood that was built for World
War II workers at the shipyard and uh
these are very modest homes and very
modest uh incomes and I uh since I used
to be a resident of Amherst I know that
Bedford is a relatively wealthy
community so I'm assuming that they made
enough noise to get themselves onto a
bill uh a one onetime bill just for them
and I think that is a process we want to
avoid too if we want to have every one
of the 49 sites sub submit their own
bill Standalone without funding asking
you to approve it I think it would be a
chaotic process and I hope you will
decide not to uh uh agree with this bill
as written thank you very much for your
testimony is there anyone with questions
for the
representative oh can can I Mr chairman
can I add something personal note new
information excuse me representative
it's new information that concerns only
this bill I'll be happy to take it sir
it's just new information about the
pronunciation of my
name now please do sir apologize it's a
seroc creation name and I'm not going to
pronounce it the way it's pronounced in
Sero creation but I would just suggest
that it is samich and I will give an
exemption to representative cluder
though
okay thank thank you for that sir thank
you we will I will try and do better
next time um any is there anyone else
114 oh I'm sorry um the chair recognizes
Genevie good please uh just uh state
your name and and unmute and we'd like
say I apologize can you hear me yes yes
we can okay perfect um I with respect to
I apologize I did not jot down um the
gentleman's name who was just speaking I
do agree with him when he states that it
is a bit of a clunky process to have
each
49 um towns to submit it individually
however there has been extensive work on
behalf of tberry Lane to go about doing
this so to vote against it simply
because each Town needs to of the clunky
process I'll just summarize it as that
um would be um passive and if it is in
fact um voted against for that specific
reason then I would like to know what
the process would be going forward to
try to push this forward um in the best
interest for the quality of the lives of
the T bery Lane residences which the
homes from what I could see have been
erected in the
80s um I'm I'm not sure what the lady's
name who was asking about when they were
when they were built but around the 80s
from what I could see just by using the
public information just quickly just a
moment
ago jie could I ask you to I believe you
asked a question of the chair and I'm
not sure what your question was can I
ask you to repeat that please if you had
a question sure the question is if the
if this is voted against the
bill I would like because because of the
reason for the clunkiness of each Town
having to submit their own case to have
a sound wall erected I would like to
know what the process would be going
forward to try to get this sound wall
erected if not just for tberry Lane then
going forward for all 49 towns that are
asking for it okay thank you uh the the
process would be to uh work with your I
believe to start with your Regional
Authority um transportation and try and
get it included in as part of a a
10-year plan or this is the Federal
process understood uh from what I
understand though it is not a Federal
Highway um it was sold to the
state I I believe you are correct in
that so there is a process um and um
that is ongoing and uh speak with your
Regional uh planning Authority and work
if it were to indeed fail today okay
thank you for your time thank
you next to
speak represent Jack is there someone
else
here
oh um the chair recognizes Chris wanek
you just unmute and U state your name
and I have have not seen you for a
couple years just like to say hello and
please uh
testify well good morning I think it's
still
morning um representative Mr chair um
and members of the committee my name is
uh Chris waschuk and I'm Deputy
Commissioner of the Department of
Transportation and what I like to do I
did I did um submit testimony which I'm
going to kind of go through fairly
quickly U relative to this bill um the
department is certainly sympathetic to
the plight of this affected neighborhood
as well as there are almost 300
neighborhoods across the state that have
noise um
issues um you know in noise is certainly
a serious issue um adjacent to our state
highways and certainly has an impact on
the quality of life of those people
living there um sound walls and noise
barriers when effectively and properly
designed will reduce the sound of
traffic um that NE negatively affect
those areas while sympathetic to tberry
Lane and those
residences um the department cannot
support this bill based on the
eligibility criteria and
funding that is TB landan does not meet
the criteria of our noise wall policy
and there aren't sufficient funds
residential areas must meet specific
criteria to be eligible for sound walls
uh that eligibility criteria
incorporates Federal requirements and
provides uniformity and consistency to
make the process Fair Statewide keber
Lane does not meet the eligibility
criteria for sound walls um the
department has a noise policy that
policy
was um well the department has operated
under that noise abatement policy for
over 20 years the first
policy um was signed and enacted by then
commissioner lean Kennison and approved
by Federal Highway in
1996 more recently in November of
2016 the department with Federal
highways approval updated the noise
policy to include both type one and type
two Highway projects type one being a
project um where there is proposed work
for example right now we have the fit
widening that is proposed on the
turnpike in nashille meramac and Bedford
um and under that project this actual
location was evaluated and I will talk
to that in one moment uh type two is a
location where there is no Highway
Improvement programmed and where there
was no prior determination that a noise
abatement measure was not feasible or
not reasonable so these policies have
really guided and continued to guide the
noise assessment in developing all of
the Department's Highway projects to
ensure consistency and
fairness
um relative to tberry Lane so this
neighborhood noise assessments were
conducted um on several
occasions first occasion being when an
airport Access Road was planned there
was an environmental impact study that
was done at that time that was back in
1997 um the final environmental impact
um statement was issued in 2001
on page
four 154 of that document tber Lane
neighborhood is discussed and it states
in that document that area 4 which is TB
Lane has a total of six impacted
residential receptors located along TB
Lane and County Road in Bedford west of
the southbound travel Lanes of the Y
Turn Pike where noise barrier would be
an effective mitigation measure at that
time a preliminary engineering
assessment identified the barrier to be
almost, 1500 ft long and cost
approximately
$85,000 it was noted that seven
residential receptors would receive a
noise reduction benefit of 58 deci
however it concluded that based on
preliminary information gathered to date
it would not be economically reasonable
uh to construct the barrier based on the
cost effective Effectiveness criteria of
the policy in November 2011 noise
measurements were taken by the
Department's Bureau of environment and
confirmed the results of the airport
Access Road FIS that at least five
likely six residences approach or exceed
the noise abatement criteria of 67 de so
um without a doubt there is high noise
levels at these
locations however based on the
reasonableness cost criteria it was
determined that a noise barrier
dislocation would exceed the cost
criteria by almost four times 115,000
per benefiting resident as compared to
the 30,000 cost criteria at that time
more recently as part of the preliminary
engineering envir and environmental
study work for the Nashville marac
Bedford Manchester project or the F
widening project um a noise assessment
was conducted and completed as part of
the environmental study for that project
as part of that project 25 noise analys
locations were evaluated along the
corridor with noise measurements from
2016 as well as what they do is they use
future noise predicted by fhwa traffic
noise prediction model 20 of these
25 uh locations were identified with
high noise that exceeds or meets the
noise
criteria 20 of 25 tber Lane in County
Road uh were one of the 25 areas
evaluated and one of the 20 areas which
included had high noise and will
continue to have high noise in the
future
the study found that an optimal noise
barrier would be a little over 2200 feet
similar to what the airport Access Road
study determined an average 16 feet in
height um and would benefit nine
residences so would benefit three more
residences providing at least a 5 deel
reduction so this would result in
approximately 3600 square feet of
barrier or 4,000 sare ft per residence
which exceeds the 1500 square foot cost
Effectiveness criteria that we have
we've changed from um a cost requirement
to a dimensional requirement it's, 1500
sare ft now per residence that is the
criteria um on page 413 of the
environmental study states that the area
is expected to experience noise impacts
but exceeds the square footage threshold
and therefore is not reasonable so no
barriers proposed as part of that type
one
project as of the FF widening project
noise barriers in seven of the 20 High
noise locations are proposed as part of
that project because they meet the
criteria for noise and cost
Effectiveness the estimated cost of
those barriers is $8.8 million which
will be funded and paid for under the
project the other 13 locations including
tberry Lane do not meet the criteria for
cost effectivess although they do meet
the criteria for noise and no barriers
are proposed is part of that project
these 13 locations would cost an
additional 13.2 million if no uh cost
criteria
existed or dimensional criteria
exists reconducted uh noise assessments
routinely as part of uh projects and
there are many locations where the
barrier is feasible so it meets the
noise reduction criteria however is not
reasonable because it's not cost
effective based on recent just and this
is just the last over the last decade um
recent project development projects
there were 29 individual locations which
were eliminated from noise barrier
construction because they did not meet
the Department's noise policy for cost
effective in total these locations would
exceed $32 million and they're in
locations in Salem all the way up
through Manchester on i93 quarter in
Newton along the Spen
Corridor in the vicinity of the airport
Access Road in Manchester Manchester
Auburn on another Manchester location so
there are many locations Statewide where
homes exist in relative close proximity
to the highway and have high noise
levels the state cannot afford to
provide noise barriers at all these
locations
um we have conducted and what
representative s said in his earlier
testimony referred L Type two um noise
assessment it's kind of a screening
study where 298 areas were reviewed and
turn keep every lane was one of those um
that document is on our website it was
done in
2017 the study revealed that 49
locations Statewide 26 on the turnpike
system and 23 on the non-turn Pike
highways meet the eligibility criteria
for noise abatement in both visibility
as well as reasonableness or cost
Effectiveness the estimated total
barrier length to address those 49
locations is 37 miles and the estimated
cost in today's dollars is 190 million
keury Lane was not one of those 49
down on that list actually they were
91st so 90 90 locations have high noise
as well as a cost Effectiveness criteria
higher than the tberry lane neighborhood
um presently there is no funding in a
10-year plan to address any of these
noise impeded locations these type two
locations um in conclusion there have
been many bills filed over the years to
address Highway noise in each time that
department cautions against approving
individual locations would suggest that
the issue be addressed as part of the
overall 10year plan process
um type two program was developed in
2016 to expand eligibility for stound
walls but it has not been
funded appropriating 1.8 million of
Turnpike funds for a project in this
location to construct sound walls when
the barriers determin to not be coste
effective is question setting and will
open an avalanche of other requests and
due to impacts of covid on traffic and
Turnpike toll Revenue delays to Major
Turnpike capital projects that are shown
in the current 10-e plan are inevitable
and appropriating 1.8 million of
Turnpike Revenue will essentially draw
on those same funds being utiliz the
capital program create further delays so
for the above reasons the the department
cannot support use funds federal funds
are Highway funds for the construction
of this are and with that I'll be happy
to answer any questions thank you
commissioner are there uh questions from
the members in the
room are there questions
from um those others in attendance
committee
members seeing none thank you thank you
for your
testimony
um wishing to speak representative Jack
is there anyone else in there wishing to
speak
seeing no other
speakers is that is that correct Jack
speakers um I will uh bring uh House
[Music]
moving right along I would like to open
the executive session on House Bill 114
at
then what is the pleasure of the
committee representative M uh thank you
Mr chairman um I would like to move U
itl on on house
bill4 if I could have a moment after
there's a second to speak to that
representative Abbott seconds it's been
moved and seconded that house bill
114 even though it's from the chairman
be found in expediate to
legislate discussion representative MCC
thank you Mr chairman and I uh try not
to do this too many times to your
legislation going forward um I uh and
former members of this
committee speaking for myself are very
sympathetic with the noise generated by
this
highway and we have looked at this for a
number of
years committee has not been in favor of
singular legislation coming before this
committee to solve an issue and uh due
to the costs associated with this in
addition to that not having a fing
source to to handle
itl I I do have one question of the
department just so that everybody is
clear if whoever from the department
wants to try to answer what I'm going to
ask um you talked about the top 49 that
that are in the criteria via one
90 uh million somewhere in that
neighborhood what if we were to go
beyond that what what kind of money are
we talking about to bring satisfaction
along all of these highways where the
neighbors
have high noise level but don't meet the
other criteria do we have a figure for
that I'm sorry representative because I
I was actually I needed to rejoin
thatp can you repeat the question and
I'll be happy to answer it um how
much
um you testified it was about for the 49
that was mentioned about 190 million if
we were to go beyond that and go to
everybody who is having noise problems
but don't meet the the criteria laid out
do we have a a ballpark figure on what
kind of money we're
talking yes that was actually I
anticipated that question so that I
asked um a staff to compile that list in
essence there are 143 areas that were
evaluated as part of that type two study
that have high noise levels that so the
noise is
exceeded um in order to address all
those 143 areas and they're both on the
term Pike system and and off the
turnpike system it's $450 million in
today's dollars and that is based on
they did an approximation of the square
footage required for each wall it's
based on the current estimate that it
costs $46 a square foot to construct a
noise
barrier uh thank you I just wanted to
get the ball park so that we could frame
the question going forward when we keep
when I keep bringing this up
uh any other qu discussion on the part
of the U committee uh for those members
of the public who have their hand raised
we are in executive session and we do
not take new testimony during uh the
executive
session um the only reason I asked the
do to come back is to get those figures
in our mind in my mind going forward
representative Thompson never
mind Mr chairman okay thank you with
some reluctance I am going to vote for
itl for this bill with all due respect
Mr chairman but I I'll tell you we've
been dealing with this committee has
been dealing with this issue for over 20
years now I was here and I voted against
a member of my own party for sound
barrier for for her area so it's an ongo
and that was I guess I could say
portsman so represent sign 20 over that
was over that was 22 years
ago we've been trying to deal but we
didn't have the money and I
think you know with all due respect
we've got to deal with this issue and I
suggest next year and I'd be willing to
work with anybody else you know prep you
know even though it's not my doesn't
really affect my area to come up with
putting something the 10-year plan to
try to re try to begin to erect some of
these s in areas that meet the criteria
at least
to deal with this and and another thing
I think represents the member from ports
repres S I hope I pronounced that name
right fail to mention he just mentioned
the highway fund some of these I think
like your bill on the turnpike so we
could take money from the turn it isn't
all the highway fund we could take it
from both depending on where the the
barrier is to be erected but the point
is that there's money involved and I
don't see I think we need to begin to
address this in the 10-year plan is the
proper venue and if we were to pass this
bill uh I think we'd have a fight and
there'd be amendments on the floor and
and plus next year even if it passed
even if it was retained there's going to
be a bunch of bills similar bills we're
going to have to consider but I think we
nevertheless I think all the sponsors
including yourself make a good point and
I think we we've got to deal with it uh
it's a matter of money uh so I I think
hopefully next year I would be willing
to to have put something in the 10-year
plan to begin to deal with this issue
because probably we're not going to deal
with it soon unless there's some federal
stimulus money that could be which I
doubt very much will happen in the next
year or so thank you any other members
of the committee have anything to add
representative
Kinski yes hi this is representative
kolansky cheser district 13 um
apologies I I just have a clar
clarification question um being newer
member uh could you clarify what exactly
the uh the motion is and what it
represents the motion before us is
inexpedient to legislate usually
abbreviated LL it means just that we are
recommending to the entire House of
Representatives that the bill be CL and
and once the house votes on that if it
adopts the
recommendation then the bill is dead not
just for this um for this year um unless
it comes back in a substantially
different format um so this is a our
recommendation would be that this bill
not become uh law and it not go to the
Senate and that that would be the end of
the bill
for uh this this session okay thank you
thank you um if I heard this testimony
correctly from the
do the benefit was for nine
residences that is what he testified yes
$1.8 million that's $200,000 the house
could kind
of philosophy on this I don't know if
it's possible for the government to
always keep the quality of your life the
same no matter what happens around it
just sounds like it's a recipe for
disaster for the state of trying
to trying to do that you know I gu you
have a concern for noise I I just
thought I'd go out stick
somewhere well and and
speaking very perally because I live in
Bedford it does affect property values
once the noise goes up and if you try to
sell the home as some of the residents
are my age or older and are looking at
their empty nesters and want to try to
to move on um the property value is not
commensurate with the rest of the
community because of the
noise um and so that's part of the
problem I understand what you're saying
about the cost benefit analysis to the
state I may or may not agree with it in
this particular issue but what bothers
um I'm just uh surprised that the
Department of Transportation is stuck on
one
solution to a vast problem when they one
of the at least the temporary solution I
don't think any of us believe that that
section of Turnpike is
done that there isn't going to be more
work done there and in an area where
it's like you said um affecting property
values and quality of life sometimes
they can go in and put in a uh an
evergreen barrier that isn't a the best
solution but it's a relatively inexp
inexpensive solution to a problem like
that I know it's been done other places
in the state it's not a permanent
solution because sometimes the
trees can't take the salt from the road
and it depends on what the layout of the
land is but it might be something for
them to look at I I agree with you
representa suggested that maybe we look
at that over the next year or so while
we're waiting to get the 10year plan I
know one time when I was in the minority
of the chairman sent me to barab back to
talk with their to Cil about that very
thing putting in a green um barrier to
help knock down the noise for a new
development that was going in um and the
and the department did look at it and
did part of it not everything that they
wanted but part of it so we need to
you're right we need to look at that um
but that is outside of this particular
bill and the motion that is before us
unfortunately
anyone else don't see any hands
raised
um with that I'll ask the cour to call
the
role thank you Mr chair motion on House
Bill 114 is inexpedient to
legislate representative makoni
I representative Mills votes yes
representative suo
I vote
Yes representative
Newton
yes representative bling yes
representative boards
yes representative kazinski yes
representative
kolansky
yes representative Thomson yes
representative cluder yes representative
hi representative eil yes representative
Jack yes representative abot yes
representative
Newman
yes representative
yes representative query
bunker
yes representative
Mr chair the vote is 20 to one in favor
of itl with a vote of 20 to one the
recommendation of itl is adopted is
there any objection to the consent
calendar seeing none will go on the
consent calendar I wish to thank the
me but um
and that that is meant in all
seriousness you have to take everything
as as it comes now
that concludes every bill that has been
assigned to the committee thus far uh
there were five we've reject all five um
I cannot tell you when the house session
will be um but we do have deadlines in
the calendar so you can sort of plan
around that um when these bills will be
heard the other piece
um the governor will provide us with the
capital budget honor about the 15th of
February I may if I can work uh with
some of the agencies maybe have some
meetings that week um because the bill
itself won't be introduced till the week
after but we can begin work sessions on
what the
agencies um are asking for
um but stay tuned for that it will be in
this same format um you can attend
remotely or in person um but as we found
out today some of what was supposedly
sent out um to the committee members has
not made it to everybody um as far as
testimony um so I will work on that now
we have an hour and 15 minutes until the
work session with uh Department of
Transportation I cannot start earlier
because it is in the calendar for
1:30 you are welcome to stay you're
welcome to um turn off your
uh cameras or whatever until
1:30 um this will stay open and up
because we're not going to close it out
and restart it um Mr Greenland will do
some I'm not sure if we Brad if you
yourself if he's
there um I would like at least the
camera to be turned up um so we are in
recess until
1:30 um you are allowed to eat at your
desk um I am not sure anymore exactly
what is open around
conquet area um I know various
restaurants have closed and reopened and
closed again um the cafeteria in the
State House is closed so there's not
that um so I shall see everybody back
those of you who want to attend at
1:30 Mr CH I have a question
yes um just I'm I'm assuming this is
okay but just to like give my computer a
break if if those of us who are on
remote if we can leave the meeting and
then re-enter through the same link it's
the Z it's the same Zoom link that this
one my understanding will not be shut
down totally just for that very purpose
Brad what Mr Greenland what do we do
since we're going to have a little over
an hour so um I can mute the or you guys
can mute the room and I can also share
my screen just putting up a notice thing
you'll reconvene at 1:30 and to
representative Evil's question you can
leave and come back but I will keep the
recording going and the live stream
going as well thank you very much I
appreciate that answer so we stand in
you
e
Jim I don't know if you can hear me but
J
e
dead hope this is all right just added a
little about no cost to
[Music]
they
have okay the time being
1:30 I'd like to reconvene the public
works and highways committee for a work
session with Department of
Transportation um if you could bring up
the commissioner representative Jack and
then whoever else she would like to have
um who else would you like to be
participating
commissioner I think initially if you
could bring up Bill Cass and Chris
waschuk and then we do have all of our
directors available as well so they can
introduce themselves to the new
committee
members I believe that Kathy had sent a
list of who would be participating today
I'm sure a couple others will be joining
us but why don't we go ahead and get
started um we have as much of the
afternoon as people want to devote to
this I don't know about you commissioner
but
Le we did prepare a presentation for
today that was emailed to the committee
um so I'm going to pull that up before
we begin our
remarks um although it appears that the
host has disabled that feature for
it can you see the presentation now we
do I can yeah well first of all thank
you Mr chairman U members of the
committee for this chance to talk about
uh the Department of Transportation it's
really nice to see so many familiar
faces with the returning members to this
committee um but also we wanted to take
this time to introduce the new committee
members to the leadership team at the
department and that's why we have a lot
of our directors available today um just
to make sure that you can put a face
with the name um in addition to the
presentation we have also um updated our
Factbook um two years ago as part of
committee orientation we developed a a
booklet that we'll make sure that you
all get a copy of it'll also be posted
on our website um it's a a handy Guide
to the department it also has all the
contact information most importantly um
for all of our subject matter experts
across the do so you know who to call
when you have a
question so who are we at New Hampshire
do um you know we are in the business of
moving people and um things from point A
to point B and our mission is to provide
transportation Excellence enhancing the
quality of life in New Hampshire
why is our work important because
really since nothing moves in New
Hampshire without the transportation
system it directly impacts our economy
and so uh first and foremost um our work
ensures that people can um get to school
get to their health care appointments um
and get out to their jobs to earn a
living um our priorities you know first
and foremost we focus on safety we want
to make sure that we're keeping the
system safe um for all you users but
then also uh that we're keeping our own
employees as well as the contractors
that work on our assets safe as well we
want to have a well-maintained reliable
system and we want to function as
efficiently as we can stretching the
value of every dollar that we're
provided uh by the
legislature this is how we're structured
uh we have three Commissioners um myself
uh we have our assistant commissioner
Bill
Cass Bill's also our chief engineer
which means that he oversees all things
Highway related both project development
as well as operations and then our
Deputy Commissioner Chris wjuk who
oversees um Finance policy
Administration as well as the division
of Aeronautics Rail and Transit so we
are a multimodal
DOT because we maintain the state
highways certainly we have a lot more
staff focused on uh both the operations
of our roadways as well as design and
construction but we work very closely
with all of the airports in the state
with the railroad operators and also
with the public transit agencies and in
every project that we advance on the
highway system we're always looking at
multimodal connections and making sure
that we're accommodating bicycles and
pedestrians as well as Motor
Vehicles project development is made up
of all of our technical uh disciplines
and so um our bridge design folks
Highway design environment and
construction teams all report to our
director of project development and
while this uh org chart that's on the
screen makes it look like we're all
quite siloed we've worked very hard as a
leadership team to make the organization
as horizontal as possible um so for
example the folks in environment and
materials and research collaborate and
work closely with those in operations um
our Aeronautics Rail and Transit folks
or also involved in a number of our work
groups and so um we're trying to share
the expertise across the
department but today we really want to
introduce you to that leadership team um
so heading up all of these different
sections um we have as I mentioned the
three Commissioners and then our
directors who I believe are on the line
um Marie Mullen is our Director of
Finance Brown bazinsky is our director
of policy and administration P Hurley
who you'll see often before this
committee is um our director for Erin
Rail and Transit Dave rodrig is our
director of operations and his assistant
is Mike citus and then for project
development we have Pete stamis and his
assistant bill oldenberg um Pete will be
very familiar to this committee um
because next year when we work on the
10year plan together um Pete is the one
that leads the 10-year plan effort we
have a project manager within our
planning and Community Assistance Bureau
but Pete is always the person who goes
out and um presents at the public
hearings across the state in the gaset
phase of the 10e plan and then will come
with us to all of the meetings that we
have before this committee and there's
two other people who are not on here um
Eileen meany is our public information
officer and so when there's winter
weather or accidents out in the highway
you'll probably see Eileen on WMUR or
it'll be quotes from her as our PI um
when there's news coverage uh concerning
the department and then a person who's
really intrical to team is Kathy um M
hson I referenced her earlier she is our
hearings examiner but she's also our
liaison to the legislature um so we'll
make sure to share her contact
information anytime you need something
from the Department you go straight to
Kathy she will uh make sure that we meet
your expectations in terms of getting
the information you might need and then
the last person who's on here is Nick
Alexander who heads up um what we call
amps but really it's our um asset
Management Group and um he works
directly with the Commissioners you know
at the end of the day I mentioned how
our priorities are state of good repair
and safety um we are in the business of
maintaining assets and trying to extend
the life expectancy of those assets and
so we've done a lot of work um to help
support the 10-year plan and the
legislature as you're making investment
choices in what the future condition of
our assets might be with different
levels of investment what outcomes you
can expect if we advance the projects
that are being programmed through the
10-year plan so the amps group are
really our data um uh collectors and uh
they're doing all the an analysis so
that we can come to you um and give you
accurate information on what you can
expect based on the choices that you're
making from a policy
perspective and the most important thing
of the day is the phone number at the
bottom of the screen um if you call that
number that goes straight through to the
commissioner's office um and that's how
you can get in touch with any of the
directors again for the benefit of the
new committee members in particular we
wanted to talk about
um the assets that do is responsible for
um we are a large organization uh we
have around 1650 permanent full-time
employees we then in addition have a
number of part-time employees especially
in turnpikes where we have part-time
toll attendance and others to support
Mission and then we also hire a number
of seasonal employees especially in the
summer months to support our summer
construction and operations
programs as a department we're
responsible for um
2161 State Bridges um you'll hear us
talk about the red list often again for
the new members a red list bridge is one
that is approaching uh the end of its
life um technically it means that one of
the elements has been rated a four when
we've gone out to do an inspection so
these bridges are safe we inspect them
more frequently if they're on the Red
List um but it does mean that uh we need
to start to advance a project to either
fully replace that structure or do a
major um Rehabilitation and so uh when
we get into the 10year plan we'll talk a
lot about what percentage of our bridges
are on the Red List in other words what
percentage are structurally deficient
and need attention sooner rather than
later and then uh we also are
responsible for inspecting both our
state Bridges as well as the municipal
Bridges and we do have some funding to
support uh work on Municipal Bridges and
um in total um there's about, 16 90
Municipal bridges that we inspect as I
mentioned you know we inspect red lless
Bridges much more frequently it's
approximately every six months uh
because they are um older structures in
many cases that need attention um and
the rest of the in uh the inventory we
inspect every two
years on the highway side um we are
responsible for approximately 4600
center lane miles of Highway um we are
responsible uh for all of the routine
maintenance although it can be a little
confusing um there's some roads that we
winter maintain other roads that we
summer maintain and so depending on
which Community we're working with um
the the role of the department might
vary slightly some of this is just due
to plow roots for example and making
sure that we're operating as efficiently
as possible so we collaborate very
closely with the towns um on both uh the
roads that we fully own and operate as
well as the ones where we um have shared
responsibilities and basically if you
think of it you know pavement lasts
approximately 10 years so our goal is
always to resurface annually about 500
50 center lane miles um so that we can
keep our infrastructure in a good state
of repair and you'll hear a little bit
later on that that level of investment
has not always been made which is why um
at different times the condition of our
infrastructure has
deteriorated and then of course out on
the highways we don't just have the
pavement itself to maintain there's all
the other roadside features from traffic
signs line striping all of the traffic
signals um not to mention drainage
structures and ditch lines and so
there's a lot of additional assets that
we are responsible
for but as I mentioned we're not just
the highway department we are the
multimodal do and so we also have 195
miles of
state-owned active rail line um we have
a number of operating agreements
um who use those Rail lines um we also
work with the 25 public use airports um
and then the 11 public transit systems
and so when we work together with this
committee on the 10-year plan we're not
just prioritizing which projects um we
want to do in terms of new construction
on our highways we're talking about the
federal funds that support our airports
and our public transit systems as
well and so this is how the budget
breaks down um just to give you a sense
of how much we spend every year um in
2020 our actual expenditures were around
681 million we like to split our budget
into these two different segments of the
pie um the blue part is really Municipal
Aid and construction that's the spending
associated with all the projects that uh
you help program in the 10year plan and
so while all of the money flows through
our budget um when we are working with
House and Senate Finance on um the
budget process it's really addressing
this Orange segment um the choices and
the investment um tradeoffs Are All Made
during the 10-year plan and then we just
plug those numbers into our budget so
the split about 419 million goes to
Municipal a and construction and then
our operating costs um last year were
around 262 million one of the most
challenging things for this committee um
to start to get up to speed on is the
various funding sources um so not only
do we have federal and state sources
um we also have a Turnpike system here
in New Hampshire and so every dollar we
collect on the turnpike system can only
be spent on the assets that are part of
that
Enterprise and then on the federal side
there's a lot of different categories of
federal money and so when we collaborate
and work on the 10-year plan um I like
to say we're not prioritizing all of New
Hampshire's Transportation needs um
globally we are trying to make
priorities and rank projects within
different categories based on on what
color of money they might be eligible
for and so next year we'll do the Deep
dive and we have um a lot of acronyms uh
and a crosswalk to all of those
abbreviations so that um you'll have all
the information you need uh to help us
come up with the next 10e
plan um so again you know this is just
more of a deeper dive on the Aeronautics
Rail and Transit division um I mentioned
previously we work with all of the
airports that are open to the public um
we do all of the runway inspections and
a lot of the Federal Aviation dollars
the FAA dollars flow through the
department um we um also administer a
number of the grants so we work with the
three commercial airports um that's
Manchester uh Lebanon and peas um and
then there are nine airports that are
what we call block grant airports so
basically New Hampshire's a block grant
state that means that there's a lot of
FAA functions that are actually
performed by um the Department of
Transportation um unlike some other
states where things are administered in
a little different way um we do have
some airports that do not qualify for
federal assistance um and that's where
uh State funding um is more heavily
relied upon um and then lastly we do
have to register all of the aircraft in
the state and um we do collect aircraft
registration fees um that are then used
to make investments in the airports as
well on the rail side um I mentioned
before that we do have active state
owned track um we have six Active
operating agreements um four for freight
lines and two um tourist lines and um in
addition to the active Rail lines we
also have a lot of corridors that were
formerly um
railroad uh corridors but have recently
um
been converted into uh rail Trails or
recreational use um because the railroad
um active rail use was either
discontinued or the section were
abandoned so um we work very closely
with our colleagues over in the
department of natural and cultural
resources specifically in the Bureau of
Trails um because they often have the
operating agreements for the corridors
that we
own and then lastly uh the public
transit um agencies um there's a lot of
different categories of federal funding
that's um allocated to New Hampshire
through the Federal Transit
Administration we basically split things
into small urban and rural providers and
so we work with a total of 11 uh public
transit systems and um we also are very
involved in um the services to seniors
and folks with disabilities um
and there's funding provided for Human
Service and volunteer driver programs um
and then we also um as a
department uh fund and then have an
operating agreement U to provide the
Boston express bus service that connects
New Hampshire uh down to Boston um that
service uh runs along the 93 Corridor as
well as um the F Everett onto the route
three Corridor in Massachusetts
and
um that service is a great success um we
pre- pandemic um we had very high
ridership and a very low subsidy so it's
a service that we're particularly proud
of and later on today we'll talk a
little bit about how the pandemic has
impacted the department as a whole but
certainly our Federal
Transit um agency uh partners and the
Federal Aviation um folks have been
trying to support the state dos and the
the car's act funding has gone a long
way to helping um all of the modes of
transportation during this
time and so Administration wise um you
know the executive office consists of
the Commissioners and the directors um
and in our budget you'll see all of the
money for sort of agency-wide
programs um and then uh of course as I
mentioned before you know all of the
public Outreach and um coordination with
the leg legislature and the governor's
office is managed through our executive
team Finance uh you know we won't come
before this committee often to talk
about the details of the operating
budget um although um as we work on both
hb1 and hb2 we'll make sure to keep this
committee apprised of any language in
hb2 that might um impact how we advance
the projects that you then help us
program in the 10year plan and um we do
look forward to collaborating we work on
hb25 and the capital budget together and
then lastly policy and administration um
as the name would suggest um our Bureau
of HR is uh within this section um but
then we also have all of our health and
safety staff um our office of federal
labor compliance um as well as uh our
internal audit section um as all part of
the division of policy Administration so
really they the backbone of the
department making sure that we're doing
everything everything consistently and
efficiently so at this point I'm going
to pause and turn it over to Bill Cass
um as I mentioned earlier as assistant
commissioner he oversees both the um
division of project development as well
as operations and so he's really GNA uh
start by digging into the municipal Aid
and construction part of the budget and
um the roles of the folks in project
development uh then he'll talk a little
bit about operations and then we'll have
Chris talk about um the funding and
how things are looking as we go into
mute thank you commissioner chairman
Graham and the rest of uh how public
works very good to see everybody um I
think commissioner you have uh you have
the control of the thing the
presentation so I'll just ask you to
advance but um and if it and at the
chair's uh discretion as we're going
through this information uh if there are
any questions and we want to stop and
pause and ask uh ask any um ask any
questions that we can answer uh during
the presentation um I I I presume that
would be all right as well too but uh
we're at a little pause here are there
any questions before we move ahead um no
but I appreciate that the members of the
committee please raise your hand so we
can know don't just jump in I would
appre
good thank you so yeah so as the
commissioner said um I was going to talk
first about the municipal Aid and
construction half of our budget it's uh
actually more than half as you can see
by the uh Pi there the 2020 expenditures
were about $419
million um and at the bottom of that
slide I just uh you can see that the
majority of the funding that comes for
the municipal Aid and construction is
from the federal program and the
Turnpike system they're very little
Highway funds uh uh and other in general
funds in there so it's predominantly the
federal funds uh the turnpike uh
primarily the turnik Capital Money uh
that comes through and uh a lot of it is
kind of flow through it flows through
the Department's budget but it goes out
to contractors it goes out to
municipalities it goes out to you know
support the economy and um all those act
activities that are um brought than just
the Department's um you know staff and
slide so uh administering all of that uh
activity and all of those construction
projects in the highway uh program is
our Bureau of uh Pro uh division of
project development and it comprises as
commissioner had outlined earlier uh
seven bureaus but essentially they're
responsible for you know the planning
the engineering and the support of the
engineering all of the right of way
Acquisitions and all of the construction
management oversight for uh the
Department's um you know Highway
construction program uh the bureau
project development is also in charge of
developing the 10-year plan the 10-year
Transportation Improvement plan um with
a update every two years and I have a
little bit more
information uh on that in the um
upcoming slides but um the Federal
Highway Administration program my
Federal Highway
program uh which really is the uh bulk
of our Highway construction program uh
comprises about $180 million per year um
that's what we get for federal funding
uh to support our uh construction
program and that's what goes out in
fy2020 um we had advertised about $192
million of construction contracts uh
some of multi-year contracts they spend
spend they span over several years so uh
during FY 2020 our Bureau of
construction uh and our and the
department was overseeing 88 active
construction projects with a total
construction value of about uh $566
million so that's just to give you kind
of a a size of the um uh program and the
activity um that that's going on out
please I had mentioned I Mr Cass I do
have a
question for the new members when you
talk about the 180 million dollar of
federal funding for
highways what what is the state's
obligation to match that unless you're
going to talk about it
later uh it was one of the issues and
challenges that the commissioner was
going to hit on
uh but um yeah so I let let let her take
it that is one of the um long-standing
issues that we'll we'll we'll get we'll
we'll cover at the end if that's all
right
yes but that's a good point so keep keep
that 180 in mind when we get to that
point at the end
um so um yeah we mentioned the 10-year
plan uh it's updated every two years and
just for your edification this is the uh
schedule so uh we'll be seeing a lot of
activity uh this summer with with gasset
and public hearings and next legislative
session um the 10-year plan the draft
10year plan that's developed through the
um work with gasset gasset is the
governor's advisory committee on
Intermodal transportation and it
consists of the five executive
counselors um that um all that activity
that's going on next the uh you know
this summer and developing the draft
plan will will land uh land before uh
house Public Works to take up next
session next uh next January but
typically um you know our tene plan we
um financially constrain the plan so
it's not a wish list um we do a lot of
discussion and education about the
funding levels that that drive the plan
so that we're not making any um
false promises uh but that people can
you know count on that you know what we
contain in the plan will be will be
delivered uh unfortunately as a
financially constrained plan when we
have constrained finances there tend to
also be a lot of um a lot of needs that
uh come up and get discussed I know you
were talking about sound walls earlier
this morning um but those are some of
those
um needs that difficult to fit within a
financially constrained plan um and and
uh I touch on it here a little uh
chairman Graham and commissioner will'll
talk a little bit more uh about some of
the challenges but we have extremely
dependent on the federal funding levels
so our Highway program we have no State
funds matching the federal program so we
um have very little
resiliency with that and compared to
other states um we are a little bit out
of a disadvantage because typically if
there were state matching funds it would
be a um you know a that much larger of a
of a of a program and address some of
those uh uh um some of those needs that
we can't get to but a big part of our
program and you'll see next year is
really focused on preservation and
maintenance taking care of what we own
first before um a whole before a lot of
focus on um you know expansion or new
facilities and uh keeping up with just
um preservation and maintenance and
maintaining the existing transportation
system that we have really um you know
takes up the bulk of our um of our
program so uh commissioner can you uh
next
slide um so this is a again just a
historical level I had mentioned the
$192 million of construction work that
we did in
fy20 um this chart just gives the um you
know the kind of historical investment
level that we have in our system uh the
big the big uh the the large uh column
in the middle which is uh which
represents
2016 was uh was a year that we had some
um that we had a uh a loan to borrow
some federal money to um essentially get
out and complete all of the
i93 uh work so you can see kind of the
ups and downs of of the of the of the
program and the level of investment
that's that's going out there I have uh
some breakdown in terms of the of the
funding distribution that uh that I
won't won't get into but again the bulk
of it is federal funding with um you
know some various programs uh alongside
it uh next slide so I talked about
preservation and maintenance and our
biggest assets and our big the biggest
part of our uh of our program is
maintaining the existing roadway system
and maintaining the existing Bridge
conditions so the pavement conditions uh
have been a big level of of focus for us
in the in the uh past few years and
within the 10-year plan we have an
average investment level of about four
$74 million so when I talked about the
180 million dollar program you know
that's
um you know a little more than a third
of it that is just going to the paving
programs to keep up with the uh existing
pavement conditions and um really that
isn't quite keeping up with everything
so the top chart there is the number of
miles uh paved every year and the bottom
um chart represents the pavement
condition in terms of percentage or of
of or or a percentage of miles in good
or fair condition so that you can see
historically we have not always um kept
up with um with the level of investment
that we need to make to
maintain the condition of the of the
highway system and the pavement
conditions so of of of recent years
since uh 2014 when there was a um when
there was a um increase in the in the
gas tax there was a Senate Bill 367 you
might hear that referred to uh in
various slides and in various
discussions but that raised 4.2 cents of
the gas tax that was dedicated strictly
to
um you know um Highway and Highway and
Bridge work um in this in the in the INT
in the near term so um we have you know
benefited from that investment um um
historically we have not always kept
pace with that investment and the
pavement condition had had suffered and
declined but um conditions have been
trending upward with that sustain
sustained investment uh over um the most
uh recent conditions so we are seeing
some of the um you know the best payment
conditions that we have seen in in
recent years and it is going to be one
of the challenge challenges that we'll
talk about later in terms of uh trying
to sustain that investment and and
maintain the roadway and pavement
condition at its current current
conditions uh next
slide you know similarly uh We've also
had a a lot of focus in the recent years
on Bridge condition and maintaining our
Bridge conditions and uh again that
investment and that focus and that
attention has been paying off you can
see um the red line there on that
condition M uh essentially um charts the
number of red lless Bridges and as the
commissioner mentioned red lless bridges
are structurally deficient Bridges they
have Bridges considered in in poor
condition and uh you can see that in
2015 we were trending in the wrong
direction we're trending with increasing
um numbers of poor and red lless Bridges
and uh I think the focus in the tene
plan and and and and on our program of
um maintaining and and um focusing on
bridge on maintaining what we have first
and foremost and investing in bridges uh
we have been driving the the number of
red lists uh down so the current number
of Red List uh Bridges is
125 um and we expect a further decline
when um when the numbers come out when
we finish uh compiling the numbers from
from from last year so that's all a good
good that's all good news um this chart
does show in the future years if funding
levels remain flat and remain stagnant
that um inflationary impacts will uh
will could undermine you know what we're
able to do and result potentially in um
you know the number of red lless Bridges
uh going in the opposite direction and
and uh starting to increase but um and
that all depends on you know our focus
and and and maintaining and sustaining a
uh the level of investment needed to um
address address the bridge conditions so
I just bring those two slides up mainly
because we have a lot of talk uh at
house Public Works and in the 10-year
plan about uh pavement condition and
bridges and they are really two of our
biggest assets that uh I wanted to give
the committee you know that um look of
where we um of of of where we stand with
those so the next part I'll move over to
the other side because it's a little
less than half I was going to say half
but it's a little less than half of the
of our budget and that's the operating
side of the budget and the operating
side of the budget really oh can you go
back one the operating side of the
budget really uh main is is all of the
department
of
uh Transportation activities and at the
bottom I've broken out the percentage of
costs there for the uh for the um
operating budget and you can see that um
that the largest percentage of of of
funding source for the operating budget
is the highway fund so when we talk
about um if we talk about times about
concerns about funding levels in the
highway funding and the and the highway
fund
um it doesn't necessarily affect as much
the the capital program the construction
program and stuff but it falls very
heavily on the um the operating budget
and the ability of the department to
continue to uh provide the level of
service that uh um that we provide so
slide on the oper uh on the operating
side um we really uh the maintenance and
operations you know a big part of the um
Statewide uh Workforce effort is
comprised of our Highway Maintenance uh
staff and Highway Maintenance Personnel
Highway Maintenance is um comprised of
six maintenance districts around the
state we have 87 Patrol sections so um
you know the the folks are staged in
those Patrol sections are are there to
be responsive to uh the local needs and
the and and the immediate needs and and
know their um sections of road that they
maintain very well so they maintain the
roads uh this time of year we've had a
lot of focus on winter maintenance and
snow plow operations although it hasn't
snowed very much lately but um it is
still that Focus through the winter of
winter
maintenance um and they're out there
doing the routine uh maintenance and
operations um throughout the year
responding to emergency events and
hurricanes and storms and flooding um
they also manage the district Paving
programs in other words the the more
routine upkeep and and and maintenance
Paving programs are um they they even
though they're put out and advertised
through the executive office through
here in conquer they are uh driven by
the um local maintenance District's
decisions uh the turnpikes bureau which
Chris will get into a little bit um also
has a Highway Maintenance component
where they Main maintain the
specifically the turnike system uh next
slide in addition to the uh Highway
Maintenance folks um there are a number
of other um operations bureaus that uh
support the work effort out there as
well too so our traffic Bureau maintains
the roadway line striping all the signs
and signals around the state traffic
Bureau is also responsible for um
establishing speed limits uh throughout
the state we have a a bridge maintenance
Bureau um which does the routine
maintenance uh on Bridges and and really
works to keep Bridges as much as
possible off the red list um keeps them
up so we have again 12 Bridge Crews that
are staged throughout the state um we've
had a uh we also have a Mechanical
Services Bureau which maintains the
state vehicle Fleet um which is a lot of
the uh plows and and and heavy equipment
and heavy trucks that are out there
plowing the roads and uh needed to do
the work um and while our main uh
Mechanical Services office and and
building is is is here in conquer out on
Route 106 off of shape Davis Road um we
do have uh six other garages staged
around the state to provide that um
provide that Regional support uh to the
Highway Maintenance bureaus and and the
activities out there also uh another
part of our activities are the fuel
distribution so we
maintain uh vehicle Fleet fuel
Distribution Center there are 90 fuel s
sites around the around the state and uh
the Dot's uh fuel distribution system
also supports a lot of municipal use
from school buses to local police to um
you know some of the Coast buses that
that we see and things like that uh and
the fuel distribution is also the
state's uh strategic um uh fuel Reserve
as well and lastly uh we do have a
transportation management center um
transportation management and operations
Bureau that staffs the transportation
management the traffic Management Center
you they maintain all of the um all of
the uh traffic management networks
around the state keeping um you know
eyes on the road uh helping uh deal with
incidences uh dispatching
um dispatching uh Personnel to uh
address those issues and also
maintaining a storm Center uh through
the winter when it's when it's
slide so with that that's a general
overview of of the two uh big divisions
of project development and uh operation
just to give you a sense in a scope of
uh who does what and and how we do and
with that I'd uh like to turn it over to
Chris wjuk the Deputy Commissioner who
kind of can who will go through um you
know some of the funding uh associated
with these activities the highway fund
the Tren Pike fund and some of the
impacts from from uh the pandemic so
Chris good afternoon um gram and work
committee members before I start are
there any questions um on material of
Bill presented for
continue okay guess I'll I'll continue
so um so the highway fund there's a lot
of talk and a lot of um sometimes it's
misunderstanding relative to the highway
fund um in terms of whether the
department controls the highway fund
this we like to present this you know
first bullet by saying that the highway
fund is not solely the do do is much
solely tribute to the highway fund it is
a fund where the unrestricted revenue
from the gas tax or road toll
registration are collected but they're
collected by Department of Safety so in
terms of any Revenue projections um it's
really Department of Safety that
provides those primarily to house ways
and
means it's also the fund where a lot of
the federal construction reimbursements
and Gaby Bond and proceeds flow into um
that's why when you when you look at the
pie chart um it's upwards of 600
somewhat million dollars it's because of
those Federal inclusions that flow
through the highway fund there's a
primary source of funding for the
operating budget like Bill noted um and
it's Revenue that that other agencies
also um draw on am of safety draws on
the highway fund BMV division Mot
vehicle official branch and Justice all
draw at some level on the highway Fund
in 2020 the last fiscal year 59% of the
highway fund was appropriated to the dot
26% was appropriated to other agencies
and 15% flow to municipalities that's
primarily BL ran Aid next slide
commissioner I I have a couple of
questions about that last slide
absolutely for the new members if you
could explain what Garvey and Tiff are
absolutely so Garvey uh fed that's a
federal bonding program it's Grant um
Revenue anticipation bonds um and it's a
program
where primarily for i93 there were bonds
issued for the construction of i93 and
the and the debt service on those bonds
are paid
um with federal funds it it is the first
staunch of federal revenue that comes
off of
our obligational limit um at the
beginning of each Federal year right now
I believe um theave Debt Service is
roughly 17 million a year to pay off
those um i93 bonds piia it's another
Federal it's a loan program it's a low
cost Loan program um with very specific
specific criteria there was $200 million
of of tifia um of the tifia loan that
was used again to fund
i93 those proceeds are paid back by the
SB 367 revenue and that and that um that
program was structured such that The
Debt Service that was payable on the $
200 million dollar was interest only for
the first seven years and then principal
kicks in in year eight
and it stretches out for a total of 20
years so um the reason we were able to
get such a fantastic interest rate on
the tifia loan which is I think a little
over 1% was we qualified for that rule
rate and we're able to do a lot of other
work um with the
s367 revenue that we pledged um in those
rural areas and it to work on um red
lless Bridges as well as Paving from of
the tier three and four roads which in a
lot of cases aren't eligible for um for
federal aid so um The W the way the
waterfall Works roughly SP 367 Revenue
brings in approximately 34 million I
think that's going to be reduced by a
little over a million almost two million
because of the pandemic over the next
biennium but anyways for example in
fiscal year 19 it brought in roughly 30
4 million um 12% of that Revenue flows
to block Grand Aid so roughly a little
over 4 million flowed to
municipalities and then the interest on
the $200
million um whatever was expended at that
point was being paid and then um 6.8
million for the state a rich
program was allocated out of that
revenue and then the rest flowed to
tifia pledge bridge and and Highway work
so um when when Bill talked about the
paving program we're able to spend
roughly 1213 million a year in
additional money out of this SB 367
revenue on Paving that we wouldn't have
been able to if we didn't have this
program and the other but roughly nine
10 million goes to Red lless
bridges that answer your question
representative yeah on those it did on
the fifth bottom of the the slide 15% to
municipalities is that in addition to
the block grant Aid or that is block gr
a okay and I thought that there was a an
RSA that set limits on what went out of
the highway fund and what percentage was
supposed to stay within
do um did we wave that in the last
budget
process um I am not 100% sure if the if
waved but I'm not 100% sure whether
because that percentage because the the
block granade flows through the through
the department I think they combin these
two percentages and that's the those are
the percentages they use the 59% and
then and
15% but the following question was about
the 59% I thought that there was a
higher um Benchmark for the department
to get out of the highway Fund in the
RSA there is a benchmark um off the top
of my head I don't know exactly the
percentage but I I'll I'll get that to
so this what this slide shows is the um
the amount of and it's unrestricted
Revenue that flows into the highway fund
so this does not include better nor does
it include the
s367 those two um sources of fund
they're restricted in the highway fund
and they have they're restricted for a
certain purpose so this is totally
unrestricted so this is 15 cents of the
22.2 cents um it and it has a 10year
look back so in fiscal year 10 um you
can see the dollar value for Top Line is
the the road tool that was collected uh
then the motor vehicle fees um in in
this year 2010 and 11 is a $30
registration sech charge um and then
highlighted in yellow are a lot of kind
of the
one-time
um infusions into the highway fund um to
prop up the highway fund um during
different times of
um different bium I would say so you can
see there's a there's um the I95 s is
included in there that is the I95 brid
sale uh for 120 million that the
turnpike purchased the high level bridge
and um reimburse the highway fund a
little it's 120 million plus interest
over it was initially intended to be a
20-year period but it worked out to be a
little over a six-year period um the
Retro Turnpike toll credits that's where
we were able to go back and get
reimbursement for f projects where the
state match was paid um and and we use
uh turn toll credits for a short period
of time those three years to go back and
Infuse federal funds into the highway
fund fund um in miscellaneous Revenue um
what that amounts to is the federal um
federal revenue our budget now um in the
first four years there that Revenue was
unrestricted and now since 2014 that
revenue is in um but if you the bottom
line if you look at um over the 10-year
period we've gone from almost 340
million of unrestricted Revenue in the
highway fund to um a little under 250
million in the highway fund um in 20 so
drop next
slide uh this is the turnpike system
um most
of you know it consists of three
segments um Central Turnpike Eastern
Turnpike which also consist of fding
andar
um so on the the central Turnpike
basically is the F Everett and that it
extends all the way up to Exit 14 and
conquered we have on the Eastern
Turnpike both the blue star which is I
95 from state line to State Line the
Spen which is from the p p traffic
circle all the way up to Exit 18 in in
Milton um so it's 89 miles long in total
172 Bridges we have eight whole
facilities now and what's important to
understand it's an Enterprise fund so
all the revenue generated on the
turnpike system must be used on the
turnpike system can't be allocated
elsewhere used elsewhere Turnpike
Revenue pays for the operation
maintenance of the system The Debt
Service on the outstanding bonds um
renewal and replacement work keep the
system in good work in order and then
any kind of Capital Improvements and
that's the kind of the flow of funds
that that goes through different
accounting units we only do Capital work
new construction when there's a
sufficient Revenue to do that all the
other areas need to be satisfied and
there's Bond covenants that um the
department needs to meet uh to make sure
that the revenues allocated and spent um
accordingly fiscal year 20 um and
primarily this includes um about four
months of the pandemic impact
there were 110 million transactions and
131 million total revenue for example by
comparison this for year 19 there 123. 7
million of transactions so we're roughly
about 11%
drop um in those four months of this
year 20 due to the pandemic we do have a
question from representative Newman
absolutely yes thank you for the benefit
of all of us and especially ESP our new
members could you specifically identify
the eight toll locations right now
absolutely so um on the central Turnpike
we have ramp tolls at Exit 10 and
meramac
currently we have the Bedford Mainline
toll
plaza the hookit mainline Toll Plaza on
i93 the hookit ramp Plaza
and then we have on the on the blue star
we
have the Hampton Mainline toll on I95
and the Hampton side
toll and then on the Spalding we have
the DOA Mainline uh Plaza as well as the
Rochester Mainline
welcome next slide please
so here's just a a graphic of the
10-year look back for the turnpike U
fund um revenue and this is the this is
the toll Revenue as you can see
um the turnpike system was fairly flat
Bally at 10 through 13 um started
increasing in 14 and then we had some
pretty good bumps particularly in the
recent past um on the TR Pike system
part of that also has to do with
violation Revenue that that is is
collected and and uh that has increased
the years past um as I mentioned earlier
in fiscal year 20 we had a roughly 11%
reduction in traffic and about 10 and a
half% reduction in the tall
slide this is a graphic that shows um
the pandemic's impacts on traffic
primarily this is at just one location
on
i93 between Exit 12 and 13 we have an
automatic uh counter traffic counter um
and we we've done is we're comparing
traffic um for each week of this example
began in February uh February 10th 2020
and then it extends to January 18 20 uh
2021 so for each week um here we compare
to the previous year the week the same
week previous year and
um and you can see that traffic was
slightly
above um the biggest years levels early
on and then the pandemic hit we had an
Abrupt abrupt drop um it dropped 50%
during the height of the pandemic um and
then it came up back up during the
summertime and now we're looking at you
know roughly at around 15 to 17% lower
traffic um at this at this location than
the previous year I will say the
turnpike system almost represents this
to a t turnike system saw traffic drop
um at about 53% at its height and we're
at about um between 18 to 20% right now
so this represents barly mostly
happening across the state I will say
that does have a question
absolutely thanks the I think it was two
or three slides previously you talked
about in a 10% reduction in revenue on
the turnpike system from the start of
the year I think it was can you tell me
what that equates to in
money yes um so that that equ to roughly
$15
million sorry was that 50 million 15 15
million on the Turn Pike
you okay
um so yeah next slide
commissioner so this
actually and there's the5 there's the
14.9 million for year2
so what this slide shows is we have um
an expert that does all our traffic and
revenue
forecasting um it's a group from
stantech it was formally a group from
Jacobs when we went to issue Bonds on
the turnpike system they did our traffic
and revenue forecasting so they have a
lot of um a lot of credibility in the in
the industry um particularly for what
what what are really graded as
investment raade type of forecast so the
blue line is the forecast that they
provided the turnike system in October
of
2019 um and you can see this could at 20
and this is just revenue from tolls it
was it was slightly below
134 million or so and then it grew over
the 10year period to reach almost 150
million um and basically I think they
were looking at about a little over
percent a fraction over a percent growth
year year-over-year in the out years um
The Gray Line
shows the most recent um is still a
draft projection from stantech uh they
sent us the information on January 19th
we asked them to update um the traffic
and revenue uh forecast for us so this
estimate is um it's with a mid mid-range
effects and what that means is they
looked at um low range impacts from Co
um they looked at low range would be a
recovery in about three years or so um
and then a long-term effect from people
working from home um with a certain
percentage probably continuing to work
from home or at least working some
period of the week work we from home and
then they had a high range which really
looked at a possible six-year recovery
with a little more of a of an impact
work from home type of um effect um and
and they recommend using the mid-range
so this is the mid-range um I will say
that I feel this is conservative but um
in any effect you can see the dramatic
reduction in year 20 um it was a $15
million um hit on on Revenue in 21 it's
a 23 a little over $23 million hit on
Reven
um if you look at the 4-year period
between excuse me 5year period between
20 and 24 that amounts to 71
million um and then over this 10-year
period 121 million um and these
estimates this Revenue estimates are
what we use in our Capital model to
determine what can be funded um on the
turnike in terms of capital work um I
know in the past and some of the
committee members have heard the
department testify on three major
Turnpike projects um that were that you
know they total probably well over $500
million um those projects likely will
have some level of delay U because of
this
impact so um just want to make the
committee aware of that and certainly
the upcoming draft 10year plan um will
have um a level of impact to those
projects included based on based on
these Revenue
slide and I believe I'm supposed to turn
it over to the commissioner talk about
issues and
challenges thank you so Chris has given
you the overview of the financial
Outlook associated with
covid-19 we want to dig a Little Deeper
um and first of all say that you know we
as a department have really tried to
step up in support the Statewide
response to the covid-19 crisis as much
as we possibly could so we have been
assisting um with some of the call
center activities most recently we've
been helping the National Guard maximize
the efficiency of the vaccine sites to
make sure they can handle the traffic
volumes as we move into these later
phases um we've also been involved in
vaccine distribution so the department
has tried to do as much as we can um to
support our colleagues in Health and
Human Services Homeland Security and the
National Guard and we very much
appreciate that you know when the
stay-at home orders were
implemented it was absolutely necessary
to um encourage people to limit their
travel as a way of controlling this
Public Health crisis and so while we're
disappointed with the revenue Outlook um
we fully understand why these steps were
necessary but the overall impact in 2020
and 21 um was approximately 70 million
and um we've been working to keep the
governor's office as well as the
legislature apprised of um how the
pandemic has been impacting all of our
revenues um during the summer months we
uh were very concerned about the
long-term Revenue Outlook so we did um
in coordination with the governor's
office defer a lot of our work um we did
not Advance uh purchases um in
particular we put on hold purchasing
equipment and Fleet that was funded in
the last budget a number of our capital
budget uh items were put on hold and we
really focused on routine maintenance um
and there was also a hiring freeze
implemented due to the revenue
uncertainty and so for example a number
of our Highway Maintenance forces uh
supported the Bureau of traffic with
line striping for the summer season
instead of hiring seasonal help like we
typically would um so that our Highway
maintainers could do their routine work
and uh traffic would have the additional
resources needed for their summer
program um so as a result we lapsed
about 38 million um because we really
focused on core activities and did not
move forward with filling any of our
vacancies now of course as we got closer
to Winter we were very concerned about
capacity um and so again in
collaboration with the governor's office
we were given authorization to start to
fill some of our Highway Maintenance
vacancies and term vacancies to make
sure that we were prepared for the
winter
season and uh you know there's been two
rounds of uh Federal relief um the first
bill the cares act did not provide any
assistance for um State dos and for
their Highway systems in particular but
there was funding provided uh to support
our public transit systems and to
support our airports with Federal
funding from the FAA um and uh from the
FTA
it wasn't until the bill that was passed
at the end of the calendar year that we
saw some relief for highway so we have
received a $41 million back stop for
lost revenue and we're currently working
with the governor's office as to how to
incor incorporate those dollars into our
budget um and when the governor releases
his budget in a few weeks um there'll be
more of an understanding of how those
dollars are going to be accessed um but
I really want to stress that the federal
funds um whether we're talking about
airports Transit or highways it was true
relief it was to account for lost
Revenue it doesn't really give us any
additional capacity it's not stimulus or
recovery it's purely relief um so as we
look into the future there's still a lot
of federal funding uncertainty um while
there's a lot of talk about an
infrastructure proposal and perhaps
stimulus um so far the focus has been on
relief we have not seen uh the details
um of what um the house and the Senate
uh would support um while the new
Administration the Biden Administration
has outlined what they would like to see
for um potential infrastructure and the
other thing is our regular Federal
funding um is provided through uh the
fast act currently the fast act actually
expired last September and there was a
one-year extension um but this will also
be a reauthorization year so while
Congress is trying to um confirm all of
the new
uh leaders of us do um talk about uh an
infrastructure deal and stimulus still
handle relief they also have to pass a
longer term reauthorization Bill between
now and September so the docket is very
full which gives us a lot of uncertainty
um so we're encouraged as a let talk
about additional investment in
transportation that will be a good thing
but we can't count on those dollars
until we see exactly how the
conversations in Congress go
but uh we are in constant contact with
our federal delegation um and uh we're
very active in ashto um the association
that all the state dos are a member of
so that we can follow what's happening
in Congress as been said many times
today we are very reliant on federal
dollars and Turnpike dollars Chris gave
you a real outlook on the turnpike side
so we need to continue to Advocate
infrastructure um other challenges um
you know as was uh shown earlier uh our
Highway fund our state funded Highway
fund um has been seeing either declining
or flat revenues this is really ju uh
due to the increase in fuel efficiency
of vehicles on the road today um people
are buying less gallons of gas so
they're paying less in gas tax or as we
call it the road toll here in New
Hampshire
um and so every bium um we have some
tough conversations uh with both ways
and means and with the finance
committees on uh what items should be
included in our budget um last bium we
were very encouraged by the support that
we saw but we were still a little short
in certain areas one of the areas it's
talked about often is winter maintenance
um certainly we very much appreciate
that the legislature does not want to
fully fund winter um if that means
cutting from other areas
because we might have a light winter and
not need those dollars so we wouldn't
want to cut um unnecessarily but
certainly when we experience um an
average or worse than average winter
that's meant that we've had to go back
to the fiscal committee and ask for
additional authority to fund those
winter
activities um and I mentioned earlier
last summer we really had to put a lot
of our purchasing on hold because of the
uncertainty um we have been under in
underinvestigated
last budget we were delighted that the
legislature supported both our capital
budget requests uh to invest in
equipment as well as increase the
funding in our budget um but
unfortunately we were not able to spend
all of those dollars and then in
addition
um know we're still trying to address
that backlog uh from the lack of
investment in the past um so I really
you know commend our Mechanical Services
folks they've been doing great work
keeping trucks on the road um because of
course we cannot be productive without
the fleet necessary to perform our
activities um and then uh of course as
well you know um a season of doing only
the essentials means that we end up with
backlogs of preventative maintenance um
and we've had some challenges even when
it comes to recruiting
um uh hire trucks and contractors to
complement our Workforce so
um across the department um I
have really been fortunate we have a
dedicated team who have been stepping up
really trying to stretch the value of
the dollars that we do have um and
people have been um very willing uh to
go above and beyond and try and help us
get as much work completed as
possible longer term you know one of our
concerns is uh as both Chris and uh Bill
described SB 367 was the 4.2 cents gas
tax increase
all of the revenue from SB 367 was
supposed to go to the construction of
i93 that big widening project between
Salem and Manchester but fortunately we
secured the tifia loan that Chris
referenced um that was a Federal Loan so
we were able to borrow it a much lower
interest rate than was anticipated um so
we saved money in terms of financing but
then the way the deal was structured and
he described the waterfall um in the
short term we paid interest only and we
were able to do all this Paving Bridge
work so when those principal payments
kick in we won't have the same capacity
that we've had and that's why the charts
that bill showed um indicate that our
Bridge condition or pavement condition
will deteriorate over time if we don't
address some of the revenue needs but of
course we're always monitoring what's
happening at the federal level to
understand what additional resources
might be available there um to offset um
the loss of Revenue um or the loss of
available available to spend on the
rural Bridges and Pavements once we're
paying interest on
93 and then the other thing you know
we'll get into all of this in the
10-year plan but the federal uh
restrictions on how dollars can be spent
mean that we can't use them across the
system so not only do we have the
limitation with the turnpike where the
dollars collected there can only be
spent on those assets um we have about a
third of our system is not eligible for
federal aid um so we're riant on the
state revenues um the betterment program
and S SP 367 to keep those assets in a
good state of repair u because they
don't qualify they're not part of What's
called the national highway system we
can use some federal money on
um more rural Bridges but we don't have
that same flexibility when it comes to
Pavements so Staffing wise um it's been
a tough year like I said we've had a
higher than usual vacancy rate um and
that's why we've really you focused on
our core AC activities um and tried to
put off some work um now as the revenue
picture is becoming clearer we've been
working with the governor's office we're
starting to backfill a lot of those
vacancies we just had to be very
conservative for a period of time when
we didn't know what the future was going
to bring and it's really exciting to see
the roll out of the vaccine now um
because hopefully by the time we get
into the summer we'll see traffic
patterns start to return to normal but
as Chris mentioned um we're still
concerned about the the long-term trends
with respect to commuting traffic and
you think about the successes during
this um uh time you know it's been
a it's been a very difficult um year for
many individuals who um have suffered
tremendous financial hardship or been
dealing with um the loss of a loved one
or you know fighting this virus
themselves um but there are some
glimmers of hope you know the deployment
of Technology um and how successful some
businesses have been at pivoting to
telor and remote work um we believe that
some of that will last into the future
so between um you know higher education
moving to remote learning um the
expansion of tele medicine uh the
expansion of telework and then a lot of
online shopping um those are four pretty
disruptive things when it comes to how
we um forecast future traffic volumes
and understand how people might be using
our systems so it's going to be um a few
years before we really understand um
what the lasting impacts of covid-19 are
um so we're trying to get back on track
we've been working with the governor's
office to start to move forward now on
some of our capital projects um that
were previously on hold um there are
some Surplus State properties that um
during the last budget we were given
one-time general fund Surplus dollars to
demolish old buildings um and prepare
those sites that we could sell them um
again that type of work was put on hold
when Revenue was uncertain but we're
starting to revisit those projects with
the governor's office and hopefully get
those moving again um and then some of
the issues that we uh deal with every
budget um State matching dollars to
access Federal Transit funding um that's
something that uh comes before this
committee because we need the dollars to
match Capital uh FTA funds as well as um
the operating State match um on the uh
Federal Highway side um representative
Graham this will speak to your
uh question earlier um so we as a as a
department um do not have the funding to
match our Federal Highway program so
what that means is most of the federal
funds are an 8020 uh match so it's 80%
Federal and to access those dollars you
normally have to bring a 20% match a
state cash match um to the table to be
able to spend the full amount um here in
New Hampshire because we have a Turnpike
system and many of our Turnpike roads um
uh were constructed and our toll network
was implemented before the national
highway system was created what happens
is we get credit for the fact that we
keep those assets in a good state of
repair but don't draw on federal funds
to do so so every time we invest in the
turnpike fund sorry in the turnpike
system with turpike funds we get credit
for that it's not cash um but it's sort
of a reward for generating your own
revenue and keeping those critical parts
of the national um highway system in a
good state of repair and so what we do
in New Hampshire is we use those credits
to match the federal funds um instead of
bringing a cash match to the table um so
if you think of it this way if the
federal government gives you $80 you're
supposed to bring $20 of cash so you
spend a hundred um what we do instead is
we get $80 from the federal government
we bring $20 worth of toal credits which
allows us to access the federal funds at
100% the downside is we only spend 80
because it's not cash it's just our way
of accessing the federal portion um so
basically while other states are
spending $100 we'd only spend 80 um so
that's why we fall a little bit behind
um the other challenge is we also get
Less Federal money than any other state
um uh we have the lowest apportionment
um despite the fact that we have a
larger population and more Lane miles to
maintain than some of our neighbors and
there's a big discrepancy between how
much we receive in federal funds and
what Vermont as an example receives so
that's something that we're constantly
bringing up at the federal level to try
and advocate for changes in the formulas
to make it more
Equitable and then lastly uh this state
a state aid bridge program is the
funding that we provide to
municipalities to replace some of the
municipally owned bridges that are on
the Red List um or nearing Red List the
state a bridge program that was funded
with SB 367 so again Chris described
that waterfall how there's 6.8 million
um that goes to State a bridge um so one
of our concerns longer term is once um
SB 367 sunsets when the i93 debt is all
paid off um then two with the state a
bridge program and that's why uh We've
really um had to cut back uh right now
in the 10year plan we have all of the
dollars programmed out um there's very
little opportunity to add Bridges to the
program before I think that gives you a
sense of some of the financial
challenges again we'll get into all the
detail next year when we do the 10year
plan sorry represent question um since
we're talking about decline in revenue
and the
rest I know that that probably in all
all honesty is impacting the block gr
Aid to communities I know in the town of
Bedford they are projecting about 12%
Less in Block brand Aid which then
translates into either doing Less in the
town or raising property taxes
how much on average are we seeing a
decline in Block band eight in from 20
to 21
say um so when we assign black uh block
grant we're doing it in a we're looking
at the prior years Revenue so there was
no reduction in the distribution in 2020
to the cities and towns because it was
based on the 2019 Revenue we are
currently working on the budget with the
governor's office right now in a couple
of weeks when you see the Governor's
budget um it'll show the figures of what
we anticipate being available for block
grant in 22 and
23 I don't have those numbers in front
of me today we'll wait and share them
when the governor releases his
budget but you have a sense given how
you've seen the revenues decline over
period representative if I
may um your question relative to
in the rsas how what percentage of the
highway
fund was dedicated to the department or
is dedicated to the department the RSA 9
colon 9 B basically States in each bium
that the department get no less than
73% with of safety getting 26% and then
1% to other agencies so from
our um percentages that we had on on
slide 18 the department received
74% now I I note that 59% is really
appropriated to the department and 15%
flows through the department to the
municipalities in the form of block man
Aid when they calculate those
percentages percentages that CL the dep
the block man Aid is included in
73% that is um required by law
comment
so so I'm sensitive to time I know
representative when you asked us to do
this presentation you indicated that you
were targeting about an hour and um
we've been together for a little longer
than that so I'll I'll try and pick up
the pace in these last few slides um so
there's a little bit more time for
questions um so I alluded to it
previously but we have 1650 permanent
employees currently at do um are
approved positions currently at do um
with a significant number of vacancies
currently um but really our headcount is
the lowest that it's ever been at the
department um because while the vacancy
rate has been as high in the past um
over uh the last uh 10 to 20 years we
have seen um reductions in the number of
employees um some of that's because of
Technology you know we've been able to
implement new Solutions and make things
uh more efficient but in other areas um
you know we really have just asked been
um I apologize my son has come to join
[Music]
perhaps Chris or Bill can speak to the
slide for a moment while I uh deal with
second I could speak to it so on the
capital budget side we were we had three
General funded
requests um 1.6 million to leverage 29
million of federal funds uh and really
the Aeronautics and Transit matching
funds and then also we had um a request
to replace our aircraft uh registration
system I believe that was roughly
$500,000 so um that those are three
requests we put forth on the general
fund side um as part of this bium
capital budget on the highway fund side
which The Debt Service on the highway
fund um side is paid out of the highway
fund we had 10 requests uh primarily
Patrol and and shed uh salt shed repl
placements or or
Renovations um a new fuel management
system our current fuel management
system is um basically um outdated and U
is no longer supported by the vendor we
need to issue a new RFP to get a new
fuel management system for the uh um for
the fuel uh distribution
Network um we had some critical
systems that development um I believe
I'm trying to think of what that was for
that's the second phase of uh Wolfie in
the work order system okay that's the
okay that's the work order system that
we're working on and so that's the
second phase of that and then the
underground storage tank replacement
program um right now The Debt Service is
being evaluated by treasury for these
requests um so I believe the highway
fund request that we put forth totaled a
little over uh $12 million
um we were trying to be um really
reasonable in terms of um how much more
highway I
believe I believe these these last two
slides weren weren't supposed to be
included in the presentation because we
talked about the bridge and pavement
conditions um we provided you know more
holistic kind of an overall State
average from historical perspective
this just shows a snapshot um in one of
the number of um red L good fair and and
and rep phrase that number of rless
bridges um Fair Bridges and then good
Bridges and you can see the number of
fair Bridges is increasing dramatically
so and the number of good Bridges is
dropping with time um Although our red
lless is declining um I think what's
happening is through our preservation
efforts the number of fair Bridges is
increasing because they're going from
good to fair and staying in that fair
category now lastly the paving condition
slide this just shows kind of a snapshot
2014 versus
2020 um where our pavment
condition in a good Fair standpoint went
from 68% in 2014 to now um 80 3% in 2020
so the level of Investments that we've
been making um in the system with the SB
36750 pledged Revenue um is really
paying
off with that I believe um open up to
any questions the committee may have
unless commissioner you have anything
else you want to add
Bill no hopefully this was what you were
looking for um representative Graham and
uh we went through a lot of material so
if the committee members who are new
this year have questions of course we're
all available to do a deeper dive with
anyone who's trying to get up to
speed a lot of material this afternoon
though commissioner I I do thank you on
behalf of all of us for for doing this
this afternoon it it is helpful for all
of us to get the refresher and for the
new members to be able to see what we
are dealing with because some of what
you have talked about will be de with in
the in both the capital and the
operating budget but it'll also all feed
after that into the 10-year
Transportation plan which this committee
works with on two of those three so it's
helpful to at least know who you are
dealing with and for them to to see it
for those who are
listening um all of these this hearing
um work session as well as everything
that happened this morning was recorded
and is available on YouTube for your
perusal at your
leisure um does any members of the
committee J representative clu or do
where go yeah I do have a qu I don't
know the question can answer the winter
maintenance expenses as of today are
there are your expenses running over
budget or under budget I don't know
anybody from dot have any idea so in
January we went to fiscal committee and
we asked for additional Authority um we
were underfunded for an average winter
and at that time we were trending
towards average um so we were given
those additional dollars um since then
the weather has um slowed down a little
bit so um right now we're still trending
to an average winter okay people um may
not think that it's been a harsh winter
but certainly we had one of the largest
snowstorms um that we've seen in in
history uh back in December when we got
over 40 inches in some parts of the
State uh thank you commissioner I'm
sorry what how much did the fiscal
committee give you again I'm sorry I
that I believe it was four and a half
roughly four and a half million four and
a half million thank you very much Mr
evil you have to unmute yes I have to
unmute I got the video going anyway
great to see all our friends from do
thanks for being here and walking us
through this um you mentioned the
federal back stop money I don't have it
in front of me now was like 41 million
or something but I wondered what your
shortfall was
overall we've heard a lot of
numbers so if I go back to the slides um
our total revenue impact was
approximately 70 million um and then our
million Okie do and I have a follow-up
question when do you have to start
repaying the um principal for the tifia
loan
2026 okay we have a little bit of
breathing
room thank
you any other questions for members of
see none
commissioner and deputy and assistant
Commissioners I do appreciate you taking
the time out this afternoon um it is
informative I'm no we'll be seeing you
when we get to the capital budget to
talk about your capital budget requests
um but at that unless somebody else is
raised their hand real quick which they
are haven't um I we'll close this work
session and thank everybody for
attending and I hope it was informative
you thank you thank you welcome and have
a good day thank you thank you everyone
everybody any members of the committee
have anything for me half of you dropped
off
already so you just don't know maybe
it'll be always two or three weeks
before we get together
again um I need to work out with Mr Shay
on how to work it and this room is
needed for committees that have 50 or 60
bills um for their use so by us giving
it up for a week or
two um it helps those committees to to
get those done and you know it's just a
Cooperative effort with what's going on
yeah okay and the house
section I'll let you
need yeah we we'll get that done all
right uh Mr Greenland I think we can
close it